for
here here comes
here
e
know
m
we
[Music]
he
e
spee
hola Uno do three
this
at
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
one
[Applause]
[Music]
n
aah
[Music]
[Applause]
really 3 2
[Music]
[Applause]
one
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
n
3 2
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
aah
[Applause]
BOS and welcome um I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the conference
um but since since it's an International
Event that's being streamed live to tens
of thousands of people right now um I
thought I was going to introduce the
conference which we did first in uh 2012
two years ago in the central
metropolitano
Theo we had like 230 people it a really
amazing party and now we've decided to
triple
it uh and that wouldn't be possible
without our sponsors uh which you've
seen throughout the day hopefully you
get to connect with them you have you
get to talk to them during the day a lot
of them have come from far away my team
at
WordPress we have people from Google and
ozero there's a lot of gifts that you're
going to get from them and a lot of
valuable
lessons uh the conference primarily is
about
you I want to introduce our team first
uh my name is G morou uh I'm going to
introduce later your host uh everyone
one that has a yellow t-shirt you can
get to for help the most important thing
is that we keep respectful with everyone
to maximize the happiness of the
conference and the event uh there's a
Code of Conduct that we' posted online
and there's a short version of it that's
on your cards alongside the
schedule uh keep your badges on that's
the only really requirement other than a
great
conduct uh as far as the
spaces uh we have made a special Cafe on
the back uh sponsored by digital ocean
we'll have food throughout the entire
day feel free to use the breaks to
connect with others feel free to talk
get a snack if you're tired if you need
a break also don't hesitate to take your
own time and use the
spaces uh I want to spend a little bit
of time talking about the themes for
today the first one is learning and it's
really important to me that Jennifer is
here today to teach us how to learn
there's a lot of content that we're
going to learn about today a lot of
content a lot of different things you
can do with JavaScript and I think it's
impossible for us to all memorize or all
or even know about these things before
today so I think it's important that we
learn how to learn and how to basically
make progress with everything that's
presented about today so that it's
meaningful and it helps you with your
work and your
lives the next major thing is we're
going to talk about how to implement the
JavaScript that is already here today
but to us to a lot of us it feels like
the future egas script 6 and how we can
really start utilizing those uh
functionalities today and we have two
amazing Talks by Jason and
Sebastian equally important I think is
the idea of not just focusing on the
code but also focusing how we visualize
data so we have Mr D talking about 3D we
have talks about parala by Evangelina
and we also have talks about
accessibility and internationalization
uh beyond the web we have a lot of talks
today about Hardware uh we have talks
about artificial intelligence uh a very
interesting thing that's happening today
and a major part of the theme of our
conference is everything that's beyond
the web uh we're very excited about
mobile we're very excited about
artificial intelligence we're very
excited about hardware and we have
really amazing speakers and demos and
presentations about that today uh
reusability we we'll learn
about how can we Leverage existing code
how can we take components that already
exist and reutilize them and I think
that's one of the important things that
builds up the community I put up some
code online and you guys can share it
you guys can utilize it you guys can
improve it and uh scalability is equally
important uh what happens when we grow
what happens when we're using JavaScript
the server um Alvaro and Tomas are going
to teach us all the lessons they've
learned about delivering messages to
like hundreds of thousands of connected
users I think it's going to be really
exciting and finally we're going to talk
about the
future uh when I was reading Andrea's
presentation title I got really excited
because he's running Java within
JavaScript which finally puts an end to
the whole distinction problem because
when people ask me what do you write I
tell them JavaScript oh Java okay I got
it so today with Andreas we can say yeah
we can also run Java inside JavaScript
and finally we're going to have a talk
with Brandon and Andreas at the end
which is why we have this space right
here we're going to get to all of us are
going to have the ability to submit
questions uh to ask Andreas and Brandon
uh how do we submit those questions
throughout the entire day please don't
hesitate to tweet talk about the
conference we have a hashtag we have a
swarm location you can Instagram and
find JSC
Argentina uh for uh all of us that
couldn't make it all of us that couldn't
buy tickets
uh we have uh our online stream
sponsored by Google uh it's on YouTube
and this link will embedded right away
don't hesitate to share that with your
friends as
well uh and last but not least I want to
introduce your host for the day
GTO hey
everyone how are you guys are you all
ready for JS com so let's try this again
I'm going to say are you guys ready for
JS com and you all have to scream yes so
are you guys ready for JS
com awesome that sounded awesome so as
KERO was was saying now we're going to
start uh with JS com so this is
streaming live so no pressure to the
speakers there will be thousands of
people watching it live right now so no
pressure at all I have to say hi ma'am
I'm I'm on TV when I was told that I was
going to be the host I was really
excited because I thought um in the
Oscars Barney from How I Met Your Mother
is going to be the host so I was like oh
my God I'm going to be like Barney and I
love Barney so this is going to be
legend wait for it Dar so right now
we're going to start with our first
Speaker she's going to be setting
everything up and as as gisho was saying
the idea is that we're going to start
with education and I think that it's
it's really great that somebody could
learn in 180 days and only in 180 days
how to code for me it was like a lot of
time I started coding when I was 12 it
was a lot of work I had to learn to code
and I was like what is this I didn't
understand everything but it's amazing
that in only 180 days she was able to
learn to code and actually that's what
she's going to be speaking about in a
few minutes so let me first introduce
you to our first Speaker she's Jennifer
the Walt I feel like she's uh the new
Filas fog from schb ears filia fog did
in 80 Days she did the whole world tour
in 80 Days and for her it was in 180
days the whole coding experience she
just learned it and the idea is that in
180 days she did one website per day one
website per day for me doing a website
is always a lot of months and she did
one I want you guys to give a very very
very loud Round of Applause to our first
Speaker which is her
so I'm a software developer but I took a
rather unusual path to learning to code
I taught myself how to Cod by 180
websites in 180 days so I grew up on the
east coast of the United States in a
suburb of Philadelphia where my family
has lived for over 250 years as farmers
and small business owners and while
there was a lot of doyour self spirit in
my community there wasn't a lot in the
way of Art and
technology and growing up I didn't have
any role models for what a software
engineer even
was so when I went to college I ended up
studying Fine Art um in part because it
had absolutely nothing to do with
farming but also because I was really
passionate about making things so while
I was there I ended up going to an art
museum with a friend and we were
wandering the Halls we got down to the
basement we turned around a corner and
we were confronted with
this why is it not coming up on the
screen
guys
let's try that
again
getting some technical help
perhaps
okay it's always R being the lead off
speaker you have to guinea Peg all the
technical
problems
so these are
you
[Applause]
so we still have a little bit of a
resolution problem but um maybe I can
keep going and hopefully somebody can
get that fixed up upstairs by pretty
soon so um as I was saying I went to
grads uh to art school and I was in a
museum and I came across this sculpture
which it's a little hard to see but this
is a an amazing sculpture it's Ron mck's
big man and this the sculpture is
incredible it's a seven foot tall hyper
realistic sculpture of a very large dude
and it's absolutely breathtaking as soon
as my friend and I stepped into the
space we immediately dropped their
voices down to a whisper it was that
powerful and I remember thinking to
myself how unfathomable it was that this
thing even existed I mean the sheer size
of this thing the weight the cost and
especially the amount of skill an artist
would need to build something so
complicated and so detailed and so
beautiful it was an experience I took
with me all the way through grad
school so after grad school I uh felt
like there was this explosion of
Technology happening all around me we
have all these amazing products that are
getting made from um open source
projects like Docker we have new
communication platforms like Twitter
wearable internet of things all these
amazing things and I realized I wasn't
satisfied with just using these
products and just start there and then
eventually jump onto something bigger
and this was appealing in a lot of ways
because you know I didn't know what I
was doing so this would allow me to get
comfortable with tools for building
websites and also how websites were even
built um but then I was left with the
nagging question of how many of these
websites would I need to make before I
moved on to something bigger and would I
ever feel like moving on to something
bigger so I said okay what if I just
jump right in tackle one big app um and
this is appealing to to me in a lot of
ways because it would get me right to
what I was ultimately interested in
doing and a lot of people have gone down
that path themselves and been very
successful but as a beginner this seemed
like a really large mountain of
knowledge to try to climb so that left
me by a third crazy option which was
build 180 websites in 180 days and it
turned out this was great for me it was
an INT learning environment that allowed
me to explore any and all ideas that I
found interesting along the way and and
gave me plenty of room for productive
failure so I set out three rules for
myself first I would build one
website one website a
day excuse me one website a day every
single day for 180 days each website
would be accompanied by a blog post and
three all of the code that I wrote would
be public publicly published on
and so throughout the project I was able
to do a whole bunch of different things
I was able to learn HTML CSS JavaScript
Ruby un rails even a little bit of
nodejs I was able to make toys games um
tools data visualizations even realtime
communication apps and by the end I was
able to build the dynamic interactive
web apps I originally set out to
do so on April 1st 2013 I made the very
first website for the project and that's
the homepage now this is just a couple
lines of HTML and CSS and it took me all
freaking day to do so it's not much but
it it was a
start and so by day three I was ready to
get into some interactive JavaScript
awesomeness uh this is random color
coming out and you can add more of those
as well and as the pulses move out they
pass by the notes and they pluck them
and they Flash and so you can add all
these different things get them all
styled up and the thing I really love
about this app is that the more
visual Beauty you put into the system
the more audio Discord goes into it so
it's a really interesting contrast
between the
two okay real fast close it up um so at
the end of the project I started using
nodejs um which gave me access to real
time data um so we got a bu of hashtags
on the screen um these are listening to
the Twitter streaming API and as those
um as those hashtags come in uh they
flash on the screen and they get tallied
up into a positivity rating so you can
see how happy Twitter is right
now and from day 179 this is aldraw and
it's a collaborative drawing up and so
here you can join with your friends and
you can um you can sketch together you
can draw messages you can mess up each
other's stuff whatever um and the thing
that's has always fundamentally
fascinated me about the internet is its
ability to connect us um in a way that
we can share ideas and um and
information in basically real time and I
think all jaw really encapsulates that
feeling for
me so those are 40 of my websites and
along with the other 140 that I made is
how I taught myself to code by making
180 websites in 180 days thank
[Applause]
you
so thank you Jennifer for everything
apparently now I have to talk a little
bit more and slower so that we can set
up the computer quickly and there's like
no glitches and no anything so I'll try
to speak a little bit slower I usually
speak very fast and move a lot so we've
just learned how to code now we've went
from nothing to learning how to code now
it's time to learn some awesome features
some awesome new new features that are
going to show up in JavaScript our next
speaker is from Brazil and he's going to
talk to us about es 7 to1 oh no that's
how Brazil lost against Germany in the
World Cup sorry I have to say it I mean
he's from Brazil we have to say
it so unfortunately es7 is not yet
coming out but es6 is coming out right
now and that's exactly what he's going
to be talking about he's going to be
talking about how awesome new features
how awesome new things we can do right
now also some other things that I can
say from him is that he's a developer at
Terra Tera is one of our sponsors so we
have to thank Tera for getting him here
and getting him to talk to us today
right now he's also the Brazil JS so if
any of you guys want to talk at a
conference if any of you guys want to
talk at brasel JS maybe you should buy
him something something give him
something I don't know we like rivaly or
something like that no we don't so but
maybe he can get us into the conference
he's also one of the makers of the es6
Rocks uh.com which is a website that
pushes uh the information to everyone so
that everyone can learn about es6 and
that's really just Define a a curent
language and then I I Define the strings
of my my application here I'm Define the
English message and the Spanish
argentinan uh messages and then uh the
implementation is pretty
simple I'm
offline okay um the difference here I'm
I'm look to the strings and then we're
just pointing to the object literal with
the
specific language and this is how to use
it I have uh some variables and then I
tag the template string and boom we have
now uh the message in hisan
so you can you can imagine a lot of
things you can do with template swing
this is a pretty pretty simple example
uh uh with
I uh moving to uh for strings to numbers
we have a lot of things in in numbers
now in a six uh one of the thing uh fun
thing is uh we have octo and binary
literals so now you can explicitly
specify if you uh this number is octal
or if is binary this is pretty useful
and we have this two methods is finished
and is not a number uh I think is as
well know is not a number is a wellknown
method in JavaScript actually we we
already have this this methods but it is
in global scope and now they're moving
to to the number object that make a lot
of sense and then
they try to fix some some uh
issues if you're uh your application uh
using a lot of math if you if you were a
hardcore programmer using a lot of math
uh you definitely uh check it out all of
the new methods in in math object we
have a bunch of new
methods we have uh also a lot of things
in uh array objects we have uh a lot of
methods like our ah. from that I will
show you ah off array. fine fil and uh
we can also super classing an array but
uh here in in this example I will show
you a he. from that takes an array from
another thing like an iterator uh here
is the JSC website and then I'm just
Square in the Dom looking through the to
the speakers and then I can specify
second argument that is um a map
function and I'm I'm using a narrow
function that we will see later and then
uh I'm just logging the the inner
HTML we have a a short hand in objects
uh if you are a JavaScript programmer we
probably you you have this common
situation uh where we have uh a name the
same name uh for the properties so if
you want to return or or create another
object you need to define the property
and the value even if they are the same
so with uh this object literal shorthand
if you have the same name you can just
put one you don't need to specify the
property and and the
value also we have the structuring
assignment here uh is a way to to Define
it's another way to define variables
here is is using the array pattern you
can just Define like this and we have
also the object pattern that looks word
but it
works
so about the main
features we have blog scope uh you see
I'm using lat in the other examples
block scope the difference for lat and
for VAR I don't know let is a
replacement for VAR I think it is but um
I see a lot of people saying that no
that is not the the a replacement for
VAR but I think it is so let Define a
variable in just the the scope so in
this example uh I'm using uh I'm
creating a a for Loop and this block I'm
creating this J variable so this J
variable just exists here in this block
if I try to log outside of this blocks
it will
fail and we have Arrow functions that uh
is well known as Lambda in other
language like python I think CP and
other language and uh it looks like a
dime bag Flying V the the
symbol so the arrow function is not
newable we we cannot uh make a new uh
aror function that makes a lot of sense
and we doesn't have a we don't have the
arguments subject anymore uh in this
eror function and this function is
always Anonymous but and we have the the
this binding uh fix it and we we know
how here's is how error function Works
in a simple way so I'm creating this
this variable it's a function and then I
Define the parel name and after the
arrow we have the return we don't need
to specify the return so it's a pretty
simple example in this constant log we
we output six because I'm I'm passing
five and then here x turn five and then
I after the Arrow X + one will have six
it's pretty simple we can have uh more
parameters so if you have more
parameters in an arrow function we need
to open and close the
parentheses and if you don't have uh
parameters you need to open and close
the parentheses like
this and if your arrow function we need
some a lot of codes uh you need to spec
to you need a body you need to open the
the curly brackets like like this the
the main difference here is that you
need to return
something
okay and here is the the classical issue
with the D every every JavaScript
programmer uh know this this issue that
uh if we have a function inside a
function and then try to to to take the
this we lost the reference for this so
in this example we will have this type
error this the log is not a function
because here the have the log uh log
methods so we already uh have a way to
to fix the this issue with es es5 and
here we just need to to WRA the function
with parentheses and turn this into
another just a sugar syntax okay we
don't have any change uh in the core of
the language uh is just another way uh
to do
something and how to use in class this
is a a valid as6 example a classical
example example we have the class
keyword we Define the class animal and
we have the Constructor and we have the
method
here we it doesn't need to define the
function keyword we just Define the the
method and we can
extend uh a class and we can use super
so if you want to use classes you can
use it if you don't want you can uh keep
with your your own
style uh about modules modules is uh for
me is one of one one of the the most
exciting features in es6 but uh it's
still changing uh we have
the the modular loader in in another uh
spec but it's still one of the the the
greatest features in in JavaScript so
here's how how to do
it I'm creating uh a file
BJs and I'm defining uh a variable okay
and of named exports and default exports
in a module and and we also can import a
module inside another module so here you
can see uh in this fjs module I'm
importing uh another module and then I
can export the default F that is a
single function but I can also export
unnam it uh this this variable bar and
for for use in my application um or in
another module I can just import uh the
name it with open and close the the cly
brackets here's an example that I will
show you later uh how to use in modules
I'm importing name it and default
exports and just using
it and how to use it today uh I'm using
now uh the 6 five projects um 65 is a
project that turns es6 code into a valid
es5 codes so why I'm using 625 and not
another transpiler like Tracer from
Google it's because 625 is a pretty
active project on GitHub I think the guy
that uh wrote the this Library Works a
full day in in this six or five projects
and uh we don't need any runtime we
don't need a extra library for using 625
so it's great and the generated code is
human readable you can actually uh open
the the generated code and you can
understand what what has happened and if
you want to use uh modules with commonjs
you can plug browser file and you can
grant or another GOP or broccoli or
whatever you want for
um so so here is an example that is in
my GitHub and I will try to uh
demonstrate so
here um uh I created this grun file that
just use 625 and use browser file and I
can run I
can I don't know if
you oh no okay believe in me I'm running
Grunts and I'm specifying that I want
to to convert my modules to
commonjs I think is commonjs
so I can uh use Comm JS so I can run
with node so here I run um in the
sample and Comm
app.js and then I have uh my modules
working with uh browser fi but if I want
to use this in the
browser I can
just serve the my
folder I can see the the
bar so okay
um the thing is I can run uh the modules
and I can turn into commonjs modules or
AMG modules so I can run in node with
commonjs I can run in the browser with
commonjs using browser file and I can
run I can turn into AMD a synchronous
models definition and I can run if I
want to asynchronous model loading in
the
browser so here's the es6 support today
and there's no bug in this uh this
charts yeah this is true Internet
Explorer uh is uh 70% of es6 uh
implementation so we have Firefox with
60 so we are almost there okay uh yes6
will be officially releasing in mids uh
2015 and if you're using Frameworks like
these popular Frameworks they are also
moving to es6 modules and another uh es6
features and here's a project that I
mentioned es6 rocks.com is a website for
spread the information about es6 and
today we are launching a new version of
es6 rocks so if you try es6 rocks.com we
have a uh a beautiful new
website and last thing to build this
website I created uh armonic that is
aesthetic side generator using es6
features you need to check it out uh on
GitHub and contribute and that's it here
is my my context uh
[Applause]
thanks okay so thank you sh for the talk
about es6 I'm actually impressed by his
ability to use a Lasser I mean every
time I do a talk and I use a Lasser I
never point it correctly but he has like
a great ability I don't know how he
really does it anyway we've learned
about es6 and as he was showing right
now es6 is not yet implemented in all
browsers so our next talk has a lot to
do with that there are two ways of
implementing something that is not still
in the browsers you have the option to
use a library which you can use to use
this method they are if they are not
there or you can use a polyfill and this
talk is about that our next speaker
works at Facebook he works with react
and he's part of the dc39 committee and
what he's going to be talking about is
about this very very very controversial
subject which is poly Fields versus
libraries so I have to say something
more apparently I this wasn't prepared
because he's still setting up so I don't
know I can say la la but anyway say a
big big big round of applause to
Sebastian marovich which is our next
speaker thank
[Applause]
you thank
you I'm sure it's
fine i' like to start off with a
question it's does anyone have a
favorite utility Library like low Dash
or jQuery or something like
that who uses low
Dash
underscore knock
knockout it's
cool isn't it great that we have this
community that we can use all these
different features and different
libraries if we want to and nobody can
tell us that we can't do it and there's
like no single company that RS our
community except do we really need this
many ways to iterate over
array do you even know all the ways to
filter an array in
underscore is it the same exact version
in low Dash or is it I think it's
slightly different depending on which
version you're
using do you even know all the
JavaScript standard Library
functions what about the ones in
es6 I don't think Brendon even knows all
the ones in es6 pretty sure let alone
all the libraries on top of it it's not
that a library is too big it's pretty
cool every library is pretty cool it's
it's has some nice features has
extensions the problem is that we have a
lot of them and each one has a lot of
different functions and the total amount
of apis that you have to learn to be
productive in this industry is huge and
it's way too much to learn so what
happens when you get a new team member
coming on to your team how many how many
special utility calls do they find in
your codebase and how much ramp up time
do they need to figure out what's
actually going on
there so why do we actually use
JavaScript to begin with it's not the
best language in the
world there's regardless of what style
you prefer there's at least one language
that's better that can compil to
JavaScript
except JavaScript is everywhere this is
why we're using it it's at least
something that a lot of people could
agree on an art industry needs a
baseline to build on top
of so JavaScript is one of those
baselines that we can build on top of
and using a standard comes with a lot of
benefits like information is accessible
tooling people to hire and so
on so by introducing Divergence in the
Library community we're actually
undermining what makes javascrip
great we're already creating an
environment where you can't hire a
JavaScript generalist anymore you have
to hire a JavaScript specialist and a
specific
library at Facebook we have a very
simple
story we use javascript's standard
Library there's one way to do things and
it's the standard way we don't have an
underscore we don't have utility
libraries and avoids a very simple
problem bike shedding it's the biggest
waste of time of all we still have to do
that but we keep that to the standards
mailing list and most of it is arbitrary
anyway so it doesn't really matter that
much so why is our industry still using
so many JavaScript
libraries well the standard library is
pretty small and it doesn't have all the
features that you may want but many
times the answer is just write a little
bit more boiler plate
code it takes you a few seconds longer
you don't take on a dependency
the person coming to fix your code later
after you left or if you're busy in a
meeting they don't have to learn some
obscure functions or to other versions
of the same functions that someone else
thought was slightly better than this
one one of the best lessons that I've
learned at Facebook is that no
abstraction can actually be better than
a wrong
abstraction and especially since
subtractions build on top of each other
they're difficult to
unwind
so proving that a general abstraction is
worthwhile can actually be quite
difficult and teaching it to our entire
industry is even more difficult it takes
time and this is a reason why standards
are slow you may want JavaScript to copy
a feature from another language but once
you look at a lot of different languages
it's not really clear which one is the
best one and you have to figure out
which one is the best one because
picking the wrong one is highly risky
because our entire industry will have to
figure that
out but there are some features to a
language that are really powerful and we
really need them and we really need them
as soon as
possible the problem is that even after
there's agreement on the value of a
specific feature there's still a long
process before is actually implemented
in browsers so there's a proposal there
standardization initial implementation
mainstream browser support and then the
long tail of browsers
right and once the browser implements it
it's too late to take it back so engines
actually optimize for correctness and
compatibility before speed performance
or early
implementations that that's why the Imp
availability looks like this because for
browsers it's way too risky to implement
something way too
early but that's not really what
adoption curve looks like like because
third party libraries don't have this
restriction they uh get adopted before
the standard even Pro proposed uh the
industry has already learned them by the
time there is a standard and at the end
of the
curve we have support for new uh
language
features but by the time the new
language feature occurs and is available
there's already 10 libraries that have
the same feature and now you have to
learn those 10 libraries plus another
language feature this is the point when
people are starting to have a strong
reaction against standards because they
already have the feature they already
have the the possibility to do this and
they don't want to learn one more
thing at Facebook it looks something
like this we use small experimental
libraries we roll it out slowly unless
you really need it you're you're not
going to use it too much and when
there's a standard proposal we quickly
roll off our experimental libraries and
use polyils instead even before the
standard is
filing so most developers won't actually
see these 10 different things of doing
things they will jump straight onto the
standards
version and I'd like to see this
happening more in our industry as a
whole so why aren't we all using just
polyfills so it's not that easy actually
there's a few problems with
it uh the primary problem of adopting
too early is that standards actually
change uh a lot during the process and
polyils would differ slightly in various
ways um libraries have these problems as
well with inconsistencies between
versions so often you never never
actually notice this but it does become
a problem when you have third party code
that depend on the uh changing standard
and the various versions of
polyfills and one of the reasons this is
a problem is because most built-ins are
on the global object or in the Prototype
and you can only have real realistically
you can only really have one version at
a time and different libraries may
depend on different edge cases that
can't be used together so if they go
unfixed for a long time which they
actually do unfortunately a lot of
polyils more and more code starts
relying on a particular version
of a
polyfill so it's very important for
these polyfills to stay up to date but
also the code that uses them to stay up
to date but you can package multiple
versions of AR scores with your app it's
not ideal but you can it's much more
difficult with a
polyfill another issue which is similar
to the one brought up earlier um is that
some people like to discourage poly
fuels because they might actually break
the
spec and and I'll explain what happened
with string
contains so this was another era long
before es5 in the new wave of
Standards uh it was before guo had
facial hair where are you so G and I was
working on a framework called Ms at the
time so Ms was extending the built-in
prototypes with some extra helper
functions and we did this this way we
checked if there was existing function
and if there wasn't we introduced our
own one so what happens when a browsers
triy to implement this F
feature the new version comes in and it
replaces the mles
version which means that the website
that relies on the M Behavior
breaks so luckily we learned our lesson
with mols
1.3 so instead of
overriding them conditionally we
unconditionally override any built-in
version
except the built-in version has an
nerability flag set to false which means
that you can't Loop over the property to
find
it so what happens with the second
statement it no longer copies the object
if the browser ever implements this
feature so this is actually the reason
why the browsers refuse to implement
this so they're they're they're both
fixed in newer versions of
mols um but mols was a popular Library
back then and a lot of websites have
deployed this
version so we I guess we could just
break them
except nobody's working on them anymore
there's no Consultants working on these
websites so if a browser in introduces
these feature it will break the
website this week in react we actually
check that a string object doesn't have
a key property so if
a browser ever implements a key property
on the string they might break old
versions of
react and I picked two examples from
libraries that I've been involved with
but I'm not the only one doing this I'm
not the only one screwing up this is
pretty easy mistakes to make but as you
can see it's not just if you try to
change prototypes it happens in library
all the
time and we just rename contains to
includes it's not a big deal browser
specs will have to find a way to work
around this it's not a reason to not to
to avoid using
polyfills there's a common
misunderstanding that native functions
are always faster than the polyils or
Library features that's not true so
naive polyils tend to use the native
implementation if it's
available but then you can end up with
the same problem that Ms did right if
the CH spec actually changes
then uh people using your polyfill might
actually break the
spec and
additionally
colleague Damian this is Rebecca we work
at automatic which is more widely known
for our open- source involvement with
WordPress and also wordpress.com and
some other products that we have um just
to get a feel for the room who here has
worked with WordPress or has taken a
look at the open source work that we're
involved with so quite a lot um that's
expected and as you probably know
WordPress is historically kind of a PHP
shop so it's potentially strange that
we're at a JavaScript conference that
said uh we're really excited to support
the the vibrant development community in
South America uh earlier this week I was
at another development conference and
it's been awesome uh we're actually
hiring JavaScript Engineers um so that's
my little plug uh we've been doing a lot
more work with our rest API and you have
heard of G moou uh Nathan Rick uh their
great JavaScript Engineers Damian at
WordPress if you're interested in
finding more uh info around what we do
um feel free to grab one of us in a word
press shirt we'll be downstairs in the
dev Zone um and walking around during
the talks and stuff um we're 100%
distributed so we don't timing on Cinema
the uh some other um I wanted to show
quickly this one uh this some of the
interesting things that people are doing
with all this stuff like this guy built
uh I think we can go to here this guy
built this um uh some sort of like panel
in web VR so so he's coding into this
floating panel and whatever he's like
modifying something in the code it
updates the the thing that he's coding
on the side so he doesn't need to remove
the headset at all he's just like you
know coding he even has like um he had a
new demo that he has like a webcam
pointing to his hands so he can see his
hands in a panel at the bottom and then
while like coding there like you know
it's funny that he can s sometimes that
the the cube that he's doing at the
beginning he doesn't know where it is so
he moves it like yeah he's trying to
like kind of it's interesting to see
like people like U setting creating
these things and like coding their own
worlds uh the last thing U I've been
working on this um also this editor for
for a while uh at the beginning it was
more like for like setting up scenes uh
for like games or things like that um
but as and I wasn't really sure exactly
what it was for like it was for me it
was useful for like um visualization of
the uh of the scene that I was working
on this example is from Scott Kellum and
he created a SAS mixing in order for
every one of us to to have it easier
when we do Paradox with CSS so you can
check this one out as
well and then another great example is
this one that comes with an article
explaining and a step by step how to do
this and it works like this you have
those different layers and as you scroll
all those layers are going one below the
other and it gives again the sensation
of perspective you because you are
actually using perspective in
CSS
then there there's option four in case
you don't get along with CSS or you
don't get along with parala in
JavaScript or you you just don't want to
write one line of code which is
something called pillar well Piller is
not really paralax it's something called
billar so sometimes it is confused like
paralax but it's not parala and it comes
with wjs is this small thing only 3
kilobytes and it has many options for
the animations like the duration the
delay the iteration and many other cool
stuff and the only problem is that once
you play it you cannot replay it that's
the well can check it out later it
works and then you add this thing which
is and W shes with some wrong loing
images but what is something like this
and full of comic sounds and all that
and yes it doesn't require sh query nor
JavaScript nor any kind of code uh you
can create
this this pillar effects which is
basically
this it's what the shes uses when all
the things appear out of nowhere and as
you can see as I scroll the animations
stre
but the only problem is as I scroll back
again the animations don't trigger again
that's a differ with Paradox and it
doesn't give the sensation of
perspective because there is non
perspective in this but you don't write
a line of code in JavaScript nor
CSS
additional so what are final
recommendations for and Paradox well
first of all um responsive first then
animations then paralax then everything
when you apply parala to a website you
destroy the the organization and the
flow of the content because you begin
creating relative absolute and fixed
elements and everything goes crazy so if
you apply Paradox before making your
website for mobile or responsive then at
the time you wanted to make you want to
make it responsive you go crazy because
the whole of your website is kind of
weird so make responsive first and then
at the animation and the
paralax but and paralax and especially a
scroller doesn't work really well
neither on mobile devices and on touch
devices what can you do about it you can
turn it off with enquir shers or and you
can use modernizer to turn it off on
touch screens yes because touch screens
and parala and especially a scroller
like don't get along really well and
what else it's better to to animate
transform property and opacity transform
meaning scale skew rotate and translate
because those are cheaper and they work
better they have better performance and
opacity as well and if you want to
animate colors you cannot use exad
decimal and because you cannot go
through an an F to a zero there's no
transition between them you have to use
rgba or
hsl um simply because you can go through
255 to zero but no from F to zero it
doesn't work that is simple changing the
mode the color mode and don't go crazy
over absolute positioning because
there's this idea that I have to
Absolute position everything and it's
not really necessary because once you
apply transform the element will have a
c Index and you can apply relative the
only problem with absolute positioning
it does is is really like the black
sheep of the family because it's and it
has like a rebellion in it and it does
whatever he wants so you have to be
certain that you can handle a lot of
absolute elements otherwise I recommend
you to go for um relative or fixed
elements but on the other hand absolute
and fix have better performance than
relative so you can like go from one or
the
other so uh and closing um choose the
best implementation according to your
project needs simply there are thousand
ways of doing Parx and nobody's going to
tell you anything if you use filler
instead of writing 100 lines of
JavaScript or if you use a library and
you don't use filler whatever is great
for your project use it and and please
try to keep keep a clean HTML because I
seen horrible things and I one of those
semantics CCI people so yeah try to keep
keep it clean okay well thank you very
much the slides are over
there okay so thank you Evangelina our
next speaker is also from Argentina he
works at at Yahoo and he's actually the
only coder from Yahoo that works here in
Argentina and that means that he for
sure is really amazing also um he's
right now working on Yahoo with polyi IO
as Sebastian was saying before and also
he's working now with format chz and his
talk is actually going to be about that
he's going to be speaking about how to
do internationalization on the single
pay shop and what I can say is I've
looked him up on GitHub and I saw that
he speak picture on GitHub is a magician
so that's what I'm expecting from him
I'm expecting that he's a magician now
with the code so give a very very very
very big round of applause to Juan
ignasio L Paso thank
[Applause]
you
that's about all I'm going to say in
Spanish because been asking if this talk
in
English uh just a
[Music]
second and there we go well no that's
not it
sorry okay so today I want to talk to
you about some tools that we've been
working on at Yahoo to help you organize
and develop we applications so that
they're ready for um users that speak
different
languages and I realized that this might
not be a problem that you have you may
be working on something like you know a
local newspaper that only publishes news
for rosiris so you may not need to
translate uh
clarin.com uh but you know if you're
Yahoo and you have 800 million users uh
spread out throughout the globe then
this this definitely an
necessity and you know this is a really
old Problem by now um and for which
there are a lot of really good Solutions
in the server side for languages such as
Java or PHP but we found that in Java
Script there are some features that
we're lacking and that's why we're
starting working on this and so let's to
put things in context um what we we're
Trend to work on is a internationalized
we applications but in in the context of
a modernware application that it's um
you know a single page application that
uses JavaScript to render in the browser
so that you don't have to do a lot of
reloads and make the spring
faster but um an issue that we have with
this Approach at Yahoo is that we have a
lot of content such as news or weather
information or photos and flicker uh
that's relatively static content that we
don't want to wait one or two seconds to
load JavaScript in order to show that
cont so to us Ser render is crucial uh
we want to show the content as fast as
possible and you know the current
infrastructure that we have for inel
that is for instance we have some
supporting
Yi uh and there's some really good
projects like chare queries
globalization is that we couldn't get
this to work on the on the server side
so um let me give you an example a bit
more concrete example so this is a
screenshot of the flicker photo page you
know the photo would be actually above
the screen and as you can see I've
marked with sarrow some key parts of it
this is mostly the metadata around the
image like the description which camera
it was taken for with and the parts that
I highlighted are actual Dynamic data
that you normally store in a database
like you know how many views the photo
had uh how many favorites or likes when
was this photo taken and you know this
is data that you actually
normally store in a database as raw data
such as you know an integer or uh a data
object so this is data that you actually
have to format somehow to display to the
user because you're not going to say uh
yeah uh this photo was taken uh 2
million seconds be after
1970 um so let's start from the
beginning with the simplest example we
can think
of so this number that you see in the
screen for 95% of you in the audience
will be the number
a,2 but for most of the figures today
who are from the USA this is actually
number one with
2s um we all know this is because in
Spanish we use a DOT as a the limiter um
for the souths but in English you use a
comma as a South mimer but you know that
in French they actually use
spaces I just learn about it because my
boss is
French
and you know don't get me started about
dates um I've been working as a remote
employee for over two years and the
number of times that I mixed up the day
and the month I just lost count uh to me
this is totally ambiguous is this the 11
of December or is this November 12 I
don't
know so it turns out that we we can
actually can gather all these little
differences the way in the way we show
and display numbers and dates in
different languages and we can put them
in a big table and that thing actually
exists and it's called the cldr the
Unicode common loc data repository it's
maintained by the same group that
actually defines the standard for the
UTF
encoding and what the things allow you
to do is say okay how do I show a number
or date in Arabic or
Chinese and again it turns out that a
certain group inside tc39 which is the
committee that defines the JavaScript
language realized this and worked on a
standard called Emma
402 which is the standard
internationalization ja API for
JavaScript and it actually recommends
that the implementations use the cldr
data so how does this API look like we
have a inel global object with three
properties number format and data format
kind of describe themselves and Insel do
collator is actually an utility for
comparing strings so you can for
instance sort uh the file names in
Chinese because it understands how uh
the old the UTF encoding works and how
you sort things in Chinese but we are
actually not using it at the moment
because an implementation in pure
JavaScript would be too
big the algorithm is really large and it
requires a lot of data so um we realize
we can't just use it in the browser so
for now I'm not going to talk about it
so how do you actually use this um well
it's really simple you create an
instance of Insel number format this
instance has a format method which take
a takes a number and gives you a con
string
with you know the number formatted
correctly uh if you don't specify
anything it'll use the local that the
user chose for the system or the browser
but you can even specify it if you want
so for instance if your application has
you know an option to change the
language of the
application say goes for daytime
formatting uh you create an instance of
Intel daytime format it also has a
format method which takes the dat
and it gives you back a string we know
the month and the day in the right
order um
so again you can specify more options if
you want and it'll give you uh date
formatted in a way that's more readable
by human you can even include the day of
the week or a long version of the
month so now that we have
this uh inpi that we know will probably
work in both Sur and browser we started
asking ourselves okay so in the context
of single page application where do we
use it how how do we use it and so given
a you know standard MBC
architecture uh we started asking
ourselves should we use this API in the
model well if we f it in the model then
we are kind of mixing up this logic
between localization with you know the
code that actually does netb fing or
database access or input validation so
it kind of didn't quite fit there and so
what about the controller well the
controller actually has your business
logic you know you know the stuff that
actually makes your application what
your what it is so why would you put
translation code there and we ended up
realizing that you know this there's a
parallel to CSS here on HTML in that
we're we have raw data that we're trying
to present somehow in a specific way to
to the user uh the same way that you use
media queries to show different styles
according to the size of the device and
with that in mind with you know this
idea of doing things in the view and
having servers at Ren we started this
project we're calling format
JS uh it's basically a set of
Integrations with highlevel view
libraries and you know you can go to
format js. and there's a lot of
documentation and information there
about both the project and the Intel
OPI and so as I said we have basically
Integrations with uh popular view
engines such as template engines like
100% dust or react as Sebastian was
mentioning a few moments
ago so I want to show you some examples
of how this works and how you can use
it and I'm going to get them in
handlebars because I think it's probably
going to be be more U familiar to all of
you here so in carts we have this format
number helper which takes a number and
an optional second argument that allows
you to say oh this number is actually
percentage or a specific
currency and again same goes for date
formatting we have a format date helper
which takes a date and a couple of
options to specify how you're going to
show
this uh show this date and so far if you
spend a little time to think about it
you can realize okay we're actually you
know formatting this data in a way
that's useful for the user but it
doesn't really have to do with specific
different languages you can use it just
for displaying these numbers and dates
in a way that's readable even if your
your website is just in one
language so now now we have this we
started asking okay so what's what's
next what more can we work on to to
extend this API and as I said at the
beginning of the talk um this is a
problem space that has been explored a
lot in server side languages and one
very successful project was started by
IBM um quite a few years ago and it's
the ICU Library International components
for Unicode and this Library U has been
available for C++ in Java for a long
time and it's pretty much an industry
standard right now and it's in fact the
same library that some browsers used to
implement the inel
API and the thing that we liked about
the I library is that it has this
feature called message
formatting and message formatting allows
you to write these sort of complex
sentences that depend on your Dynamic
data and this is the kind of things that
are actually kind of hard to do without
some help from software you know you
know you have to start concatenated
strings and doing awkward things with
your code that mixes up your actually
translations with your data so for
example in this case we have a portion
of the sentence that depends on the
value of a certain value such as num
likes in this case and the rest is just
Syntax for special tokens that refer to
values in your
code um again so messages already nail
about numbers and dates so you only you
also have small herpers as tokens that
help you with numbers and
dates for giving a date in the past
calculate the difference between that
date in the past and now and give you
that difference in a way that's human
readable so if you had a late um 24
hours
ago and you specify just use format
relative it'll try to give you the best
Feit possible and then say yesterday
which makes sense or if you can actually
force it to use numeric hours but I
won't just give you you know just the
number 24 it'll just give you it will
give you an part of a sentence that says
as 7 qu so 24 hours
ago so um to wrap this up I kind of want
to take a little step back and try and
answer uh a question that has been asked
to me a lot lately because uh around um
a couple of months ago we announced uh
that we are not working on Yi
anymore and so one of the reasons that
we are not working on it is because um
of how the ja JavaScript ecosystem looks
like nowadays uh we've seen in the last
couple of year Lally an explosion of JS
Frameworks and libraries that is really
hard to keep up with and you know some
of them are really good and we wanted to
use them and that was actually pretty
easy to do um
so we have kind of like a kitchen sink
for that here um this is the example you
can choose the number of neighbors to
clusters so this means that you know uh
this will if you put more neighbors
there will be less clusters with with
more edges basically and what you can
interpolate here is between the initial
state of straight lines to the bundle
edges you can play a bit with the margin
which is the stuff we added to to have
this kind of like bundle weight uh being
taken care of um you can color by clust
as I showed before or you can color by
Direction so in this case edges that
start from a blue point to a red Point
are like the direction the direction is
encoded in that so here it's not very
easy to see how many edges are going
from one place to the other and and vice
versa so what we did also is we we
extended the algorithm to sort a bit the
edges when you're creating the bundles
to group the edges going from one
direction to the other and so now it's
it's a bit easier to see that about half
of the edges are going from one place to
the other and so
on um
yeah so on Sports uh the audience for
sport is like pretty geeky right it's
like they always like to know the exact
stats and goals and like yellow cards
and so on so we had a lot of fun during
the World Cup uh with this um this uh
this interactive visualization that uh
was
[Music]
I
pi
it's
[Music]
in
the
[Music]
again Here Comes Here
Comes
[Music]
oh
te
[Music]
sh
and they also sell parts like Arduino
they do the um there are arduinos that
you can sew into clothes I think it's
the Ada of fruit Flora they do now you
can also do um conduct conductive thread
so you can take an Arduino sew it into
your clothes take conductive thread and
sew in LEDs and different things like
that it's really neat and they have
instructions all over online I worked
with a 13-year-old girl who made a
sweatshirt that has directionals on her
back so that when she rides her bike she
can just hit a button in her sleeve and
she has an arrow on the back of her
sweatshirt which is pretty cool um and
they have all the instructions for
things like that on Ada
fruit they make this really neat stuff
that on the top left is makeup that's
conductive makeup so these girls put um
conductive material into makeup put
these LEDs on their foreheads and it
looks awesome I mean if you were walking
down the street it would be really
startling but it looks really neat I
think that tie changes color with music
a lot of this stuff you maybe couldn't
wear to work every
day um but uh it's really neat there's
videos on online and like I said they're
on my blog as well but you know that
Google and other and other Enterprise
are using fast graphic CPUs I don't know
how to
say that can be TR can be used in
accelerated Hardware to train n networks
you you don't need to use only
JavaScript let's go
sorry and the last live demo is
something that I like personally
personally I like oh English is the same
to way is that do do have an hbd
approach to generate programs instead of
genotypes what is an evolutionary
War
you have a
war uh full of grass the green uh is the
grass and you have animals
predators that can H take food from the
gas the Predators that has has um a
random program that say oh some
something in in with some way you can
eat if something is random because the
they select the best animals in the
first generation and generate new
animals that notice that there are few
grass now because the animal now are
have better programs to Pro to to eat
and to move in the in the war and you
have
better
programs and better
programs each program each population is
generated a vype but this is a program
not not not have script at least can
modify its own structor you can modify
the program in JavaScript and generate a
new
program
okay that is the the
end
but what is the problem with all this
approach is a soft artificial
intelligent no baby needs to
see 1,000 pictures of a cat to recognize
a
cat no no of this Al no of this
algorithm knows has knowledge about the
domain they attack there are only
algorithms we need to explore like in
the initial years of artificial
intelligence we need to explore the hard
way of artificial intelligence one thing
that we need to do is to create really
an intelligent engine that can be uh not
play in in Toy Wars but in a real world
not in a
in a simulated War but in a real
war this is an image a bad image but is
an image for the the book the um
artificial intell mod approach um the
idea is to have an intelligent agent or
maybe an artificial life agent you you
don't need to to push all intelligence
in one piece in one step
maybe the step is to have an Asian that
is an artificial life Asian instead of
having all the knowledge all all the all
the intelligence we have as human one
thing to explore them it's not both and
related things that
really um Works in Real Environment not
in simulated
environment oh I I am proud in my voice
okay that is the idea of the
talk all the resources the demo the
project and the and the different um
things I read are in the in this uh
GitHub rep
[Applause]
thanks
okay so thank you anel are you guys
ready for continuing we are like one
more talk uh before the break so it's
just one more talk and our next speaker
is from automatic he works with gisho
and the folks that spoke before from
WordPress and I really like this talk
because it's about not taking things for
granted I mean a lot of time when we're
doing programming we're copy pasting or
doing things like that and I like the
fact that he's talking about
alternatives to eils so that we don't
take all those things for granted
another interesting thing about our next
speaker is that a few months back it was
his 10 year anniversary for writing his
first commit on open source and that's
incredible for me because 10 years ago I
was still in middle school so it's
amazing that he it's been like 10 years
for him so one of the hard things about
being the presenter is when people comes
with really hard last names which is
this case so I will try to speak it okay
and uh we'll see so give a big round of
applause to Nikolai
biski hey everybody um I I will start
with a with an old joke so
a programmer is about to leave to the
grocery stores and and and her husband
asks her honey can you please buy some
bread and if there are any eggs could
you please buy a dozen
and and and she goes to the uh store she
comes back and you can imagine he his
his surprise when she brings back a
dozen loaves of
bread so we obviously have a a have a
problem here right so what if the
problem is in the if
right if he if he didn't give her any
choice uh there wouldn't have been any
any trouble right
so unfortunately computers are really
bad at at working without if a claes or
without branching in general without
switch without Turner re operators and
stuff like this
because they will be able to do only one
[Music]
thing and this is not really good right
and culturally people we also really
like choice because we can't live other
otherwise without choice right we we are
we really need it so we will have to
look at the problem somewhere else
and where else would would be would be
the
problem people talk about if a lot but
people rarely talk about else and you
can see that in in English
books the word
if is actually seen more than 10 times
more than than the word
else which is a lot so people like if a
lot lot more than else
and however in in computer
programs uh the world uh the word if is
actually seen only four times more than
else which is which means that in
computer programs we have 2.5 times more
else Clauses than if Clauses why is
there such a such a big difference
between natural language and code
because
we're kind of supposed to to express
with code what we want to say with
natural language right
and I I I will try to uh to give you a
few reasons but but first let us try to
track a typical logic statement with ifs
and eles right
um we we have an if with uh condition
one and this piece of code will will be
executed if condition number one is true
right then this piece of code will will
be executed if if both conditions one
and two are true right then we go to an
else
where we have to change our context in
in in in the sense that condition number
two now now has to be false when when uh
we are trying to read the
code and and this help and the same
thing happens for the rest of the house
Clauses we have to
always do a context switch every time we
we are we are reading an else
and historically context switches has
been really hard both for computers and
for
people doing doing our our everyday jobs
so before we continue let let us look at
what what would a statement containing
only only if Clauses would would look
like without any any eles um we will
have to remember that uh this code will
be ex executed only when only when the
first condition is true this code will
be executed when both the first and the
second conditions are
true the next piece of code will be when
all of the first three conditions are
true and finally the the last piece of
code will be executed only the only the
only when when all four conditions are
true so we don't do any context switches
we just we're just adding more more
context and in general for for people
and historically change is
bad PE people never never like change
but people actually like building stuff
and they like adding more and more stuff
nobody likes my grating laptops but
everybody likes new new laptops right
and so now I will I will I would take
another TR explaining why there are so
many
more L else Clauses in programming
compared to in in natural
language and I think the reason is that
El Clauses help
us help us explain a much more
complicated logic
and and we use a more complex logic a
lot more when when we talk to computers
than when when when we talk to people
because computers are a lot better at at
understanding logic right and
unfortunately people are not at all
great at at at understanding
logic
uh we we are just too lazy we are too
bored too too easily and people also
fall really easy for logical fallacies
but I don't know how many times have you
tried to uh trace an algorithm you wrote
and it is always incredibly annoying to
to keep all of the state of in our minds
and and it because people are just
inherently not great at following State
just ask the uh react
guys
however people were really great at at
at Rec recognizing patterns I'm pretty
sure you can all read this even though
it is not any meaningful text
right um just people are really good at
uh for
example as you can see they're really
good at at recognizing text even though
all all of the letters in the middle
have been scrumbled they're also really
good at
recognizing at recognizing faces
immediately
um I'm always amazed H how border
Control Officers let me in and out of
countries really quickly even though in
in my passport my uh photo looks like
this but it but it usually Tak them like
half a second to make sure and to know
that I'm just the same
person and usually it takes so software
because they they now have those small
cameras it takes the software usually a
few seconds at least um people are are
also really good at recognizing sounds
um if you know a song usually you you
can recognize it just from a from a few
beats and usually it takes it takes some
like 15 second exerpt right so in a lot
of sense we are even a lot better than
uh
computers at recognizing various
patterns
and science has has totally confirmed
that our brain is is basically a huge
and amazing and really
fast pattern recognition machine
actually there have been some uh studies
showing that that our brain works work
works really like a recursive
probabilistic fra fracto which actually
science is trying to use for for
recognizing
faces um
so from all this we we can draw a pretty
simple rule that if in our programs we
use more patterns and less else Clauses
it it will be much easier and it will
take a lot less time for the person who
reads them to understand what is what is
going on um and by patterns I certainly
not necessarily mean uh design patterns
but from from the genga for book if
you're fans of
those um in in my remaining time I would
try to show you a few examples
of Tricks about how you can eliminate
else Clauses from your programs um the
the first one which is probably the most
common and easiest is is to emphasize
the the essential part or or the main
flow of our code um here is a really
typical example where we if some data is
is valid we do we we do something with
it and it's and if it's not we return
false right or no
sorry I'm I'm sure everybody has has
written a lot of codes for for
situations like this and see we
can the essential part of the
code is is now in pink and and and this
where we actually process the data the
rest is like uh there is a really neat
term called accidental complexity which
is all of the stuff we need to write all
of the plumbing we need to put so that
our our programs work the way we
intended them and here is a very quick
way to make sure that that our essential
com complexity the important part of the
code is emphasized if we if we first
bail if there are any any errors we can
achieve a few things first all of our
essential code can be can be together
also it will not be indented some
somewhere further in in our program so
that we know if if something is is in
the main indentation level it is
probably something important and not
just er error reporting code or error
checking
code the
other another trick to eliminate else
Clauses is to use
polymorphism actually you used to think
that that polymorph uh phism was a
multi-headed monster from from the Greek
myth mythology but it turned out that uh
it is it is the method
of of being able to use the same Lo
Logic for for a data with different
types and I'll give you an another
example here I'm sure everybody has done
something like this we have to render a
field or or whatever object and this
field can be uh can be in different
types like in our case if it's a text we
render an input if it's a if it's a
number we we have our special component
if it's a text area we we render a text
area or we throw some some
exception so if if our goal is to
eliminate else Clauses here here it will
be pretty hard
and we we can go back to polymorphism
which to remind you is to find a piece
of code which can work somehow with with
any type and the common pattern here is
that for each type we have a specific
component we just render
and for for example in instead of
keeping all of our structure in if
Clauses we we can keep it in an object
and we can use the type as a
key I'm sure all of you have have done
this A A lot of times it is not rocket
rocket science and I see a lot of people
actually do it uh but it's important to
to remember those tricks when when we
have a bigger application or or we have
a really complicated expression and and
we want to and we want to eliminate El's
one by by one
so fism
uh there are a ton of ideas there about
how to do that so people really love p
uh patterns and actually they will often
see patterns where non where no P
patterns actually exist um for examples
for example there are experiments
showing that if you start showing people
random
dots when when people are overwhelmed
they actually start seeing patterns
because because our brain cannot handle
a really complicated World our our brain
is always trying to make sense of the
world around us and for example when
when you get more and more dots which
are to totally random for for example
here it turn out that a lot of people do
not see random dots but they start
seeing pudos
right or you've seen PE people looking
at the clouds and seeing I don't know
monsters Bears or people looking at that
uh had already drunk on coffee coffee
cups and trying to uh predict the
future it's our way of
telling uh it's our way of that our
brain tells us oh it's all to uh to
complicate it I I I want to make it
simple again um and here is an example
where it could be a problem in in few
places so it is it is really important
to have our patterns in a in in in a
much simpler ways like for example if
this was in an object we couldn't it
wouldn't be so easy for
us for us to break the
pattern the a next trick is to is to put
more focus on on on the action we are
doing and not so much on the intricacies
of the
logic
here is an
example here is the logic of a of a kid
in a in the a spring season basically
anywhere in the world if it's a week day
it goes to
school if it's not a week day but if
it's a Saturday it plays it plays
football and if it's raining it watches
TV because they can't play fo football
and on Sunday obviously kids have to do
their homework some sometimes and if
it's win we like like Bears really like
to uh
hibernate so how how can we make this
simpler because when you look at it you
don't see any any actual pattern it is
just a random logic going back and back
and forth
and here is what we can do we can just
focus on the action themselves and and
not so much on the conditions
people
humans
uh as as are are pretty bad at keeping
state so they usually try to avoid it
and very often we are pretty explicit as
in what we say uh so we will usually not
say that oh if it is spring I will go
and and if it's a weekday I will go
somewhere uh in instead we we usually
say oh on a spring on a spring sa
Saturday I would go play uh football and
and you can see here that it is really
easy to see the the pattern of all the
important stuff and these are the
actions right
um sometimes it it is really hard to
escape the conditionals and and we don't
have to go into too much trouble so if
there is no visible way to escape from
them at least the least we can do is is
to simplify and make everything shorter
by by extracting stuff we we can extract
me methods for example this monster
thing can just happen this by extracting
a function in the middle and giving it a
proper
name or or or we can extract a
conditional and again G giving it a a
proper name um if people tell you that
they don't like so much
obstruction it is really important to
point out that this is in Direction and
not abstraction we're not AB abstracting
thing too much we're just putting it
inside the in a very well- named
functions and usually it is pretty
obvious what what do they do um as a
closing I would like to say that writing
code is actually a lot closer to user
experience and usability than than than
we
think because uh our cross it's it's a
normal person and we need to make sure
that when when they read our code it is
easy for uh uh uh them to understand
then and it doesn't take them too much
time um in the end people are a lot more
important than than computers and as Mr
abson said in the really great structure
and interpretation of computer programs
that computer programs are written for
for people to read and only accidentally
for for machines to execute thank
[Applause]
you thank you so thank you Nikolai for
the talk um I've just seen some of the
videos that are going live and I saw
that if I if if looks like I'm a little
bit overweight as Susanna gimenez says
it's because the TV makes you fatter
like 10 pounds it's not that's the only
reason so right now we'll have a short
talk from the people from mango they are
presenting something something today and
they are one of our sponsors so a big
round of applause to Pablo
[Applause]
Sanchez
on
m
um
[Applause]
col
graas
[Music]
I could lift you
up I can show you what you want to see
and take you where you want to be you
could be my
luck even if the sky is falling down I
know that will'll be safe ins sound
we safe and
sound I can feel your
cup you know my River won't evaporate
this world we still
appreciate you could be my
look even in a hurricane of BRS I know
that we'll be safe and
sound we safe and
sound
we safe and
sound we
sound I could show you
love in a TI way for mystery you'll
still be standing next to me you could
be my
love even if we 6et under I know there
will be safe and
sound
[Music]
[Applause]
we
I could lift you
up I could show you what you want to see
and take you where you want to be you
could be my
luck even if the sky is falling down I
know that we'll be safe and sound I can
LIF you
up I can show you what you want to see
and take you where you want to be you
could be my
love feel if the sky is falling down I
know you will be safe and
sound we safe and
sound
[Music]
we
take we s
[Applause]
this
[Music]
the like a broken balling
chain take the pleasure and the
pain and
[Music]
be
the
[Music]
Here Comes Here Comes rain again Here
Comes Here
Comes
[Music]
Here
e
[Music]
n
yeah
[Music]
should
just
[Music]
s
for
[Music]
now
oh
you
[Music]
found
[Applause]
[Music]
there's
taking your time now
I
[Music]
I you're taking your time
now and I want
you
[Music]
I'm you
clely
[Music]
I to feel with
[Applause]
[Music]
you
I
your
[Music]
I thought that I could leave it
all
behind
from the I saw
com I thought that it would take it off
my
[Music]
mind I thought that it would take it all
my
mind from the moment I saw it
[Music]
com the moment I
coming
I thought that it would take it off my
mind
[Music]
leave from I
it I could leave it
all
behind
[Music]
from that I could leave it all
it
[Music]
think
about think that
[Music]
the
let me show you the
[Music]
way about
the let me show you the way let me show
you the way let me show you the way let
me show you the way let me show you the
way let me show you the
[Music]
way
e
[Music]
was
knows love
[Music]
know
love
[Music]
know
I couldn't have you if I
said
[Music]
I could you I
without your
touch 3 2 left
[Music]
to's to it's what's left to it's
what's it's
what's it's what's
[Applause]
there's your
TCH without your
T without your
Touch without your touch
[Music]
1 Your
Touch without your touch
without your
[Music]
touch
he
[Music]
I feel all
right outside I'm
outs
[Music]
the outside
the
feel
hey everybody is ready to
continue okay I'm still kind of asleep
that's why I still have my coffee I
actually asked for a coffee and they
gave me something like this and I was
like yeah I need to keep awake so give
me a little bit more so I asked to be to
make it full but I really need the
coffee but now I'm here to talk about
our next speaker our next speaker works
at stripe and he has been doing a lot a
lot of Open Source stuff he has worked
with a yep no yep no shees he has done
uh CSS color guard and also he has done
message format.js so without further
introduction please give a lot of
Applause to Alex seon thank
you hey everyone uh it looks good I
think they're going to stretch it I need
your uh
is that you did that earlier
right can do it if you oh yeah I I have
the
power stretchy this is
responsive uh slides this is a media
query for Argentinian
widescreen I don't think it's R all
right we look pretty good now uh so I'm
going to be talking about component
libraries uh and you might say well
what's a component Library which is what
everyone at my company said when I said
hey let's build a component Library uh
so I tried to make it easier for them
everyone had heard of
bootstrap uh and so at work I started
working on something called boot stripe
it's pretty
good you'll get it it'll come to
you
uh so I encourage you to build your own
component Library uh mainly so you get
to make your own something strap uh JSC
strap uh what whatever you want to do
stripe strap didn't work quite as well
as boot stripe uh so that's what we went
with but uh why write one at all you
could just build your application and
then when you get to a button you style
the button and then when you get to a
drop down you style the drop down uh
just like we've made web applications
for a really long time uh so I've
prepared prepared a list of facts that
are definitely true about CSS the first
CSS fact is that once you write a line
of CSS it can never be
deleted it sounds like a myth but if you
think about your app you're always just
a little too scared to remove code and
so you just add new
classes uh to go over those ones so uh I
like to call CSS uh an append only
language was good
uh you get code like this this is my
favorite I always see blocks like this
you put this on a div it it literally
does
nothing but you're you're like well is
it overriding the padding is it I'm just
going to leave this here uh this is fine
I think it's not hurting anyone so never
remove it uh yeah so the fact twoo is
pre-processors are great as long as you
know exactly what the output uh this is
my favorite uh way of looking at
nesting very common output for you jip
lovers this is like a uh your best case
scenario though so that's that's pretty
great CSS fact three is that no two
people write CSS in a similar way uh I I
feel like I work with some of the
smartest people in the universe and this
is probably about as best as I could ask
for literally every type of casing and
then some casings that don't actually
exist so yeah I'm sure you recognize the
naming schemes from your own code and
that's why you're
laughing uh so CSS fact 4 is you cannot
test CSS uh it doesn't run in a way that
you can get stuff out there's not really
a good joke for this one so I'll move to
CSS 5 uh so you can't upgrade to a new
version of bootstrap without an animal
sacrifice
and I decided not to include an image
for that
one so deleting code and testing
actually go hand inand uh the easiest
way to feel comfortable deleting
something is to make sure that you have
test to make sure it doesn't break
something whenever you delete it so
component libraries are well tested and
highly reusable libraries for for UI
components uh
they would be ridiculous to test if you
did them inside of your application so
in a component Library you're often
testing that when you hover and it's
active and the keyboard focuses on and
you're looking sideways that the the the
thing comes around the edges of the
button correctly and if you did that
inside your application every time you
had a button that would be ridiculous uh
but luckily with a component Library you
can kind of focus on those nice detailed
things and so uh the reason why this is
important is because uh this is me on a
good day it's probably my best outfit I
look really sharp I had a recent haircut
I'm next to something involving art
uh it looks like everything even matches
my my clothes are on the right direction
it's pretty good day for me uh the code
that I read on this day is going to be
well intentioned I'm clear thinking and
I'm going to do things for the right
reason uh this is me on a normal
day was about 90% of the time 99% of the
time maybe and component libraries are
all about making sure that this version
of yourself doesn't ruin the app for
everybody so use your best days to build
up components that you can use
mindlessly on your worst
days so you can do things like keyboard
accessibility I put in a fancy thing oh
responsiveness there you go uh oh I
don't know actually how keynote trans
transition Ians work so forgive me that
was sweet Focus States it's the only way
Focus States can be interesting is if
they
sparkle uh so active hover Focus like I
talked about before and that's real we
really have styles that if you have been
using your keyboard and you're pressing
down and your mouse happens to be over
something like you can't have some weird
State that's a real State and you've
never considered it before I hope uh but
I hope you do in the future uh because
of of this stuff so it turns this this
uh very crappy but well-intentioned uh
Mario Clay you know it's fully sculpted
like there was no instruction manual
there's nothing anyone can do to help
you make your perfect uh fairly flawed
uh Mario and it turns that into this
which is you know you have building
blocks you have pieces and you have
instructions on how to put it all
together and so we do the same thing for
boot stripe we have have this
documentation that looks beautiful on
this screen and we have what something
is we have how to use it we have
examples of it being used and that
really helps create consistency for
developers on how they integrate things
but also helps create consistency for
your end users every time that they
encounter a button every time they
encounter a nav menu they're going to
know it's going to work the same way
each
time bonus uh everyone has like the
admin toolbar backend thing and it's
really great that now uh whenever we
build these stupid crappy internal
applications you can just use your thing
and it kind of looks like you tried
that's just bonus uh so how can you make
a component library or more specifically
how can I make a component Library uh
and it's going to be any better than
just using a bootstrap out of the box
and that's a good question you you
probably could use bootstrap for a lot
of stuff but bootstrap's core competency
is genericness it wants to be the
Baseline it has no styles on buttons and
it's fairly accessible but everything
looks the same and people are pretty
tired of bootstrap websites by now if
you get in on bootstrap 4 early enough
maybe that'll be cool for like a month
or two so first thing you want to do is
choose a
pre-processor uh not strictly necessary
but really helps uh if you're parsing
CSS you can do a lot of the testing
things that we're going to talk about at
stripe we didn't choose uh a very normal
one uh we wrote Our Own uh called KF CSS
uh I you guys have KFC here either way
uh so KF CSS is actually just a set of
modules on top of rework CSS uh so
mostly we're using open source plugins
to do a lot of the things that you like
uh it'd be similar to like myth if
people use myth uh it it tries to model
CSS 4 as closely as possible so this
would be really good for Seb talk talk
where you're kind of more poly filling
the future than you are kind of creating
your own magic we also kill things like
extend so we don't get crazy nesting and
we just deal with writing a class name
twice suit CSS is uh a good starting
point we don't use suit out of the box
but we kind of forked it and uh made it
work for our needs this is from necklace
out of out of Twitter and this is uh
really good for creating encapsulated
CSS components so you can reason about
your code uh in in nice little cool
blocks that that you know exactly what
they're doing so uh here's the example
on on the naming conventions which is
mostly what CSS is is a set of naming
conventions uh and you can say this is a
component and people like their eyes
bleed whenever there's a capital class
name but you get used to I promise it's
kind of like when everyone tells you jsx
is so ugly and then they use it and
they're like oh jsx is actually pretty
cool uh this is great because you can
always tell what is a component in your
classes and and what isn't and then you
have uh structured ways of saying this
is a modification or this is a
descendant or this is uh something else
and so you can kind of get rid of this
whole problem that we had uh
earlier you can add in your own checks
to your system and I'd encourage you to
add in checks into like you can write
rework plugins more or less if you if
you choose rework in order to jump into
your CSS and pick out things that are
important to your Oran organization one
thing that bugged me at work is uh color
checking so I wrote uh CSS Color Guard
uh if you've seen that and CSS Color
Guard uh is actually fairly useless but
uh I I thought it was a cool idea and we
use it uh kind of at CI uh continuous
integration testing time uh but but to
show a good example here's guo's post
today from uh on Facebook about the road
TZ yesterday uh Road TZ JavaScript and
let's say you wanted to know the color
of of those three buttons you could use
Dev tools but all of us have gone
through the uh the real way that we
would do this which is to zoom into a
million
percent I drop the
darkest middle
point of the
E and then it works every time that's
definitely going to be the correct hex
code so luckily there is an algorithm
that people in the television industry
uh created called C e2000 sounds like a
robot which is also cool uh they they
wrote this hella matthy formula for
figuring out uh the
differences of of colors to humans so uh
something with a low score would be very
similar a zero would be the same color
and so like yellows are kind of uh
harder to discern the differences
between then something like blue and so
it's not actually just like compare the
two hex values and so you can get this
really fine grained way of saying how
similar are these two colors and then
you can yell at your co-workers
automatically and say like hey this blue
is clearly should be Facebook blue uh
and you're like two hex characters off
how about you just switch it to our
style guide color uh also you're
fired uh we have a lot of apis at stripe
we have a API for firing people so it's
very
simple uh oh the best part about writing
CSS Color Guard
let's go back to that page I'm going to
run through all these again
uh the
CED 2000 algorithm this super mathy one
that was an mpm module so I got all the
credit uh and someone else has to do all
the math Pro
tip so uh here's an example of one of
our test pages so you can test CSS uh as
long as you're testing something very
small welldefined and and relatively
declaratively so so uh this is uh two
ways of uh marking up a switcher or
toggle so you could kind of toggle
between those three things and we have a
disabled State because uh there's that
and we have an active State we're using
the is active and is disabled which is
from the Su suit CSS naming scheme and
you can kind of see the three different
ways that those look we're not clicking
on anything we're not doing anything but
uh we can run that through uh our uh CI
server we can take a screenshot of it
and we can make sure that it doesn't
change unless we wanted it to change so
if you accidentally change the base blue
color you accidentally change your
pseudo States and that way you don't
have to use a mouse to go in and then
drag over it and then try to take a
screenshot exactly as you click down
with the fake mouse and then pull out
and and it's never good especially when
you're you're dealing with uh you know
SCE Labs or something that that you you
don't even have control over so that's
never good uh so you can do all this and
then you actually get a much bigger page
uh with all the different states and uh
like I said before there is the is
active Focus hovered State there and it
looks different than the other states
and it's correct and good uh so we run
this test every time we make a commit
and if anything changes say the margin
around the buttons we get this diff that
says hey uh did you mean to do this and
that'll actually fail the build if we
want we can commit a new image uh and
say we intended to do this uh and then
you can actually see the change that
happens uh and this seems like a cool
video that I put together but this is
actually just the onion skin swiper from
GitHub so now we have a rule that in
order to make a change in bootst stripe
a designer must sign off on any image
changes so now every time anything
visually changes in our entire Library
it either fails a build because it
wasn't supposed to happen or a designer
says this looks correct and and it's
okay um but basically involves creating
a s laabs account and
uh like encrypt You Know Travis has a
way of encrypting environment availables
so you can encrypt your username and
your and your uh authentication key and
then it knows which repository you're
accessing so there's an example of uh
what Travis C's Matrix would look like
it's a little blurry but you we're
specifying browser name browser version
um and in in a matrix Style and a couple
tests are failing there so we'd want to
go in there and clean that up
right so you'll need to create a SAU
laabs
account um there's free ones they're
called Open
sauce um and you you uh you can you can
basically create as many of those as you
want so Zuul integrates with sauce Labs
like I said by checking the en
enironment
variable and so somewhat annoying but
you have to create a new s laabs account
for every module created um I'm going to
have to like Ping their support on that
pretty soon or something but it's a
little uh it's a little Annoying my my
one password looks like this by now so
it's kind of it's kind of
ridiculous hopefully they'll make that
process easier
soon um so then of course hopefully in
the end you get
nice it's essentially autocomplete for
translations so uh this is the text that
a translator would potentially have to
translate and here is uh the machine's
best guess and so uh it's relatively
good the guesses are relatively good and
uh but sometimes when it's a little less
sure it'll present a few options and in
this case is not actually correct or
this is perhaps a better translation and
then you can kind of accept the rest
so uh so again that was something that
we didn't design for when we built quill
we didn't think about uh ways to improve
the experience for a translator but this
something that you could build and I
guess the point uh the main point of of
quill is that is its API and it's able
to do this because it has one and so uh
to conclude I kind of want to step back
from quill specifically and uh talk
about apis in general uh if you think
about products and everything as a graph
then if you just offer something without
an API it's essentially a terminal node
that's all you're going to get but if
you offer an API then it could be part
of a larger offering and it could spawn
many more products and many more ideas
so uh when you are building kind of
those products and services i' encourage
you to think about that if you want if
you want your offering to be kind of
that's all the offering is or or if you
want to kind of open the doors for
something else that you didn't think the
rest of the talks and some more awesome
stuff so 15 minutes please be punctual
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
[Applause]
no
[Music]
oh
on
[Music]
uh
h
[Music]
uh
I could lift you
up I can show you what you want to see
and take you where you want to be you
could
be I be
[Music]
and can feel
your you know my River won't evaporate
this where we still
appreciate you could be my
Lu even in a hurricane ofs I know be
[Music]
[Applause]
and
and I could show you
love away the mystery you'll still be
standing next to me you could be my
love
[Music]
even
I could live you
up I can show you what you want to see
and take you where you want to be you
could be my
Lu even if the is falling down I know
will be safe and sound I can
you I show you what you to see and take
you where
[Music]
you
we
[Music]
this
you take the fear
away and be my l in the rain
like a picture on a
frame my in
[Music]
the a broken
chure
andain and be in the
rain every you
take
every shock you can
explain all
[Music]
the
Here Comes Here Comes The Rain
here comes
here
[Music]
again
oh
the whole mindset so this is uh for me
really really really nice to be part of
this so uh this is the B basic
introduction let's do some some demos
and see if this is
working Let's cross fingers this is hard
this is the the the first one this is a
sumobot uh this is all uh the whole
project is open source so you can
download the cut files and and print the
the parts using a 3D printer or a ler
cutter and we I'm using in this project
the spark uh microcontroller so the
spark is connected to Wi-Fi I'm going to
check if everything is working right now
so I'm going to plug it uh this will
connect to to the spark Cloud there is a
cloud that will also have this uh
robot the internet let's see he's trying
to connect to the network okay it's
connected and I'm going to run the
application
two
oops so let me execute this really
quick
connecting so my my computer right now
will act as as a web
server okay let me show really quick I
wanted like to execute it from the cell
phone but the connection is not working
right now but I can send comments to the
to the bot I'm using the manual version
because I can
whoa
thanks nice
catch well
I I wanted to control the B using the
the Smartwatch maybe later uh the
internet is not working right now but
well no problem uh this is the the other
project it's called the node copter it's
an
Arron see if it's uh
connected
me it is
good
M will told Will told you this afternoon
this is like running a web server so I
can control this uh from a web
application running Express and
socket.io uh let me see if I can control
it so this has like a Wi-Fi hotspot so I
need to connect to the Wi-Fi hotspot
and do the magic but it's not
working
nice okay okay
okay okay same is working so meanwhile
this is connected I can show you other
other projects uh this one
is uh uh GA or quy is like a Colombian
folk instrument mainly used to play the
ga to play Kumbia anyone he kumia anyone
like kumia Kia Vegeta or oh great that's
good so uh this is the this is like
running a web server I'm using the bigle
bone
black this has like a mic so each time I
I talk or it the S noise he he will like
uh change the the color PN but the is
like you can haveck your own musical
instrument and create like really fun
stuff so let me see if I can play
[Music]
[Applause]
it
hey thanks good working
woo
so let
oops let's see if the other are working
in
meanwhile oh perfect I think we we are
we are on time so I'm not the musician
but I like some music projects this is
one I basically I've been working on
this is a drum kit so I'm using like a
pad like you can play some sound can I
have a audio here oh I have a real great
thanks
perfect thank you let me plug it in so
what I'm doing with this project is
mapping the kits the keys
with with some samples from a Rolland
real drum kit so you can build your own
instrument so let
me play
it I'm going to execute
it it's
[Music]
working sounds
good okay so you can create music even
with
[Music]
electronics it's another instrument that
you can build
okay this this connect this is uh
connected right now this is so unstable
right now because I crash it like a
multiple
times I'm not a good pilot there can
I uh see the the screen
please can you focus the the screen of
the
video I I want to show
okay so yeah let me
check check the express application okay
so I'm going to to execute the it's an
application called the web flag so you
can
control
uh you can run like an Express server
and using soet iio you will be able like
to control control uh a notb from your
web browser so I'm going to enter to the
express
application okay this is the camera of
the Drone right now this
is the thing maybe it will crash but I'm
going to try to fly it so stay
away
whoa go up go up go up go up go up go up
no not to me not to me not to me not to
me
okay woo work and this isn't like web
application you a no that it's fine and
you can see real
time really quickly you're going ask
what it is this is not R2D2 head I know
I don't kill R2D2 it's have you heard
about an instrument called the
thine it's kind of a a speci of terine
let me see if it's working working so uh
what I'm doing in this project
is I'm going to run it real quick Studio
okay I'm using like the right sensor to
control like the nodes like the
frequency and the left uh sensor there
are ultrasonic sensors so it measures
distance so I'm using it like
to to to control sound so can I see the
okay thank
you let me check this not you see is the
second
one so I'm using like a a web
application written by
substack it's working
okay so I'm changing the the frequency
only using the the distance so I can
play some kind of music and then I can
add some really nice
[Music]
Distortion so you can play with you can
create different experiences maybe in a
party or something when you can use
sensors and control the lights and as
you can see the the frequency of the
sound is changing
this is all written in JavaScript so you
can create your your your like music
uh look like your music function so it
would work uh very good and the last one
was the clumsy biped this one uh I have
time to play it or we're done done okay
so this is a bipad that using eight
servos uh it it seems it it will work
[Music]
but time time is over
right okay it's
sad okay
okay let's see I'm I'm trying to teach
him like to walk but he's not a really
good walker so what do you call the like
the
clumsy the clumsy bed so it has like a
some problem walking but let me check if
I
can if I can run really quickly here
[Music]
okay this is not like he he's trying to
walk but he's not a really good walker
so you need to to teach him oh try to
dance so it's really difficult to
control like the eight seror uh at the
same time but I'm using like joury 5 in
all of the experiments it's a really
powerful like uh
Library uh if someone want want to play
with it later uh we are going to stay
here until December 10 and the main idea
is like to help with the local
community and to to to have some notebox
experience here so we we brought some
adrino kit so the idea is like the next
week maybe we are going to to give a uh
Workshop here and since uh the I
received my first kit
as as a gift in an event I want to give
this like as a gift for the community
too so if you want to keep
this this robot in Argentina and keep
playing with it
so I've been in contact with with
Alejandro y he is one of the leaders of
the not school community in Buenos Iris
so Alejandra if you are here this is for
you and this is for the community so uh
uh this is my my my presentation and I I
will invite you that uh keep working
together keep working community and
please thank you and welcome to JSC
Columbia next year see you
there Alejandro pick it
up if you are here let me know and this
is for the community thank
you so thank you Julian also thank you
for the present this is mine right I
want to fly it I mean I like it it's
mine
so I gu not
anyway so we are again behind schedule
thank you Julian but the demos were
really cool so it was worth it um our
next speaker is from urai so this is a
moment where I would like to make the
politically incorrect comments like mate
is ours Carlos gardel is from Argentina
as well but Gish Mo doesn't let me so I
won't say that because everybody knows
it so now that we all know that let me
introduce our next speaker as I said
he's from uru he's he works with rabbit
mq on pivotal he's the co-author of
rabbit mq in action and he's going to
talk about how to make distributed data
integration systems with rabbit mq so
give a big round of applause to
[Applause]
alela no
come
on no no no
let's
okay so hello I'm I'm going to give the
talk in English but first I have to say
some stuff in Spanish considering what
Mr GTO just said to introduce me
so
[Applause]
for
play
so the talk of today is about rabbit mq
how to build a data Ines system with
rabbit this is a one hour talk that I
should compress into 20 minutes so let's
see how it goes plus my
jetl uh that's a book contacts whatever
uh the idea of the talk is to kind of
say what can be done with rabbit not
necessarily how to do it we have plenty
of tutorials on our documentation on the
website so if you really want to see the
code for nodejs of course uh Java PHP uh
python closure net husk whatever we have
it
there and yeah this is an actual tweet
what even is a rabbit
mq so rabbit is a multi multi protocol
messaging server it supports nqp by
default basically the big banks in the
States created nqp or started the nqp
protocol or project as a way to spend
less money not sure how that succeeded
there in doing that considering the 2008
crisis but that's outside of the com uh
and yeah rabit support mqp by default
and then mqtt which is a protocol like
for the internet of things and stuff
like here he was just
showing it's also used for example by
the chat on on Facebook on iOS they use
mqtt and stomp is a text based protocol
that for example is used at the New York
Times for websocket because it's a text
based protocol so in JavaScript if you
want to do browser messaging stomp is
the best protocol for that and it's also
used in Switzerland at CERN for example
so if you want to read more this the the
blog
in rabbit is a polyot system so you can
connect from all these uh clients and
more of course node uh Ruby airlan PHP
java.net and closure hkale and many more
the thing is that the most of these
clients or actually yeah all of them are
maintained by the rabbit mq team so they
are all well maintained libraries or
that's what we want to believe uh I'm
the responsible for the PHP library for
example
uh yeah is there anybody using rabbit
yes Instagram indeed telica Mercato Li
New York Times mosil the company that
does the effect the special effect for
the Lord of the Rings or now the hobit
the use rabbit and many other companies
next how do you actually use
rabbit so I have a simulator here this
is the only probably JavaScript part of
my talk uh by the way I if
yeah I don't
know I don't want to let's let's move
on let's not get
into finals of South American
championships so let's focus on the
talk so in rabbit what you want to do
usually is to have a producer that wants
to send data to a
consumer and the way to that's the basic
thing that rabbit should do
right B so then the the consumer can
subscribe to the queue and there you can
get the messages to
to from the que to the consumer and if
you want to speed up things
like like like for example you go to the
subte metro and you you want to buy
tickets and it's kind of going a bit
slow then of course the government will
add more people there to work and sell
you ticket faster they always have coin
and and like change that's uh very
typical to get coins there and then then
rabbit will do I mean if you have more
consumers it will do run robing and send
messages across the the consumers doing
kind of round rowing so this is the
basics of an
mqp uh you have the producer that wants
to send data to some
consumers the data is sent to an
exchange that's the address and the from
The Exchange is routed to the queue just
to explain this a bit more and then I
move on with the talk you may wonder why
you need an exchange why just not send
the data straight to
the to the queue like why don't
take uh from Switzerland when you go to
buy tickets to the train station you can
say I want uh International tickets
or I want uh local
tickets so when you arrive to the to the
station and you say I want to buy an
international one they will give you a
they will print a ticket saying you are
on the queue for international which as
usually in Switzerland they they are not
so friendly with foreigners so they
don't have any Val to sell International
tickets but if you buy and buy they're
really friendly with foreigners by the
way
and they if you want to buy local
tickets then they go to the other queue
and of course you can add consumers to
this queue that's um as usual so the
exchange in the case of the direct
exchange is choosing cues based on the
routing Keys here uh you cannot see it
so well but says International and the
other binding key says
local so in messaging you usually have a
an envelope that has like a routing key
in this case like the address where you
want to send the message and you have
the content
rabit mq should not check the content as
the guy from the post office should not
do uh the the message rabbit will just
check this envelope headers routing keys
and whatnot and decide where to Route
the messages and with the other
algorithms we can do more advanced
things like with the topic exchange
which I'm not going to show because it
going going to take a a bit of time you
can actually use some kind of patterns
to decide how to route messages so it's
a bit more advanced if you use loging
for example it's really easy to say I
want to listen to logs which are
warnings coming from the application one
on server one for example and I only
want to listen for logs coming from
server two but whatever they are
warnings error info I don't care you can
use some patterns to to implement that
so that's how mqp kind of works uh we
have the producer sending data to
Consumer The Exchange we have an
algorithm that will route messages to
qes and then the data will arrive to the
Q in rabbit or in nqp there are many
things that we can add to this mix for
example consumers on this side can
decide to act the message that is to
confirm to the broker that the message
was successfully
processed the publisher can request the
same from the broker the publisher can
request to the broker to confirm when an
F sync was sent to the hard drive to
actually persist the messages rabid mq
will do that every 200 milliseconds if
let's say you have a cluster with five
rabbits and you told rabbit to that
replicate to three nodes when those
three noes did the F sync then rabbit
will send this confirmation back to to
the publisher and some more things based
on this is what we can implement
the problem solution that I want to show
you so let's say we have a distributed
app if you can see that this is related
to the Amazon uh availability zones or
regions actually so you have Brazil
Virginia Ireland and
Singapore or Uruguay because if you
leave Uruguay nobody knows what Uruguay
is except maybe argentinan they know
it's a province to the
east beside that like you go to holidays
there
and Norway did you say Norway yeah
Norway anyway so you want to send all
the stuff I mean you are collecting data
here think for example you have a game
application this happened uh it's a real
use case some user had their game app
collecting data all over the world and
they wanted to analyze the logs in the
state probably to detect cheating or
stuff like that so they want to
replicate the
data this looks like Javas but actually
it's elang with a very interesting
syntax uh sorry for showing some elang
here
um how do you send data to Rabbit you
get a connection and you get a channel
and of course there are options to to
open the connection I'm not going to go
there and once you have a channel you
will send a command saying exchange
declare the exchange name and the type
of the exchange direct uh in this
case and then if you cannot read that is
this is the very reason why nodejs kind
of beat Aang on popularity who can read
that uh so I'm sending a message basic
publish to some exchange and the message
has some properties and some
payload and on the consumer side I do
the same I get connection on channel and
on the channel I create an exchange I
create a queue and then I connect the
queue to The Exchange once I have that I
tell rabbit I want to start consuming
messages and then I start looping to get
uh the messages from rabbit and do
something with the messages
so this is all nice we have this
deployed on each region in the world but
we want to replicate
data so we want to be hired by the NSA
with all things and send everything to
the to the
states how do we do that of course we
can have our own solution as you can see
one exchange can have more more than one
CU bound to it so we can just add a
parallel process that is just
replicating data coming into an exchange
to a remote uh
machine but the problems that we may
have with that is that what happens if
the remote server is offline like how we
prevent Unbound local buffers like we
cannot replicate data but we are
collecting them in cues and then those
cues start growing and growing and
growing we may run out of dis space or
memory or something like that how do we
prev message loss what happens if the
message was written to the network but
the remote machine crashed then we lost
the message or we were not even able to
write to the network or
whatever there is a meteorite falling on
the other side of the world I don't
know how do we prevent to send the data
that we don't want there anymore like in
messaging is very common that we like we
have let's say 10,000 messages per
second or 100,000 messages per second
those numbers in messaging are not big
numbers uh like when people say this is
a scale problem and you and they mention
1 billion messages per day that's
nothing 1 billion messages per day is
actually 11,000 per second so for
messaging apps it's low
actually that means some data can be
really old and we don't want it on the
remote machine for example of course we
can Implement all the stuff with rabbit
uh on our ourselves but rabbit offers a
better solution which is uh the
Federation
plugin this is a plug-in that comes
directly with rabbit when you install
rabbit you can just enable the
plugin and it can do replication across
many data centers you can mix Airline
and rabbit mq
versions uh yeah sorry rabit is not
written in in node uh supports Network
partition that is if the remote server
is off Line This Federation thing knows
what to do or should know what to do and
you can tell what to Federate if you
enable Federation doesn't mean every
message will be replicated you can tell
rabbit I want to replicate this and not
that for example and you can create
theologies like this one you can say
this an upstream server and the data
will flow to the downstream servers in
like this uh topology you can do like a
circle and tell rabbit how many hopes
the messages can
do so you don't have like an an infinite
Loop and yeah it's just a plugin and
internally just using cues and exchanges
so it's not seem magical that you
couldn't implement the thing is it's
really there uh many companies use it
actually in production big companies
like the one in charge of paying the
salaries in the states is using this so
if this doesn't work I will probably not
be here I will be floating in the in the
Tigre Delta maybe I don't know anyway
this is very dark
now it's the lack of mate you know when
an uruan start lacking m is like I'm
kind of shaky now and you can configure
at run time using parameters and
policies those commands enable the
plugin and let you manage the plugin and
then how do you actually Federate
something you just tell rabbit I want to
create a parameter of the Tha Federation
after stream called my upstream and then
you tell uh uh Yuri where to connect and
that's it rabit will know how to connect
to
that and then you tell
rabit every exchange whose names start
with amq Dot in this example it could be
uh images logs whatever that exchange
will be Federated and
replicated and that's
it by doing that rabit will set up like
uh this thing here this is your Upstream
uh server the Federated one imagine this
link is not there let's say this is
Brazil and that's the states you have
your publisher sending data to The
Exchange and in the queue here are some
consumers processing data fine when you
do this two commands rabbit will create
this ghost cue there it will create this
link and the Bindings that you see there
it will be replicated here so this this
queue up there will know what to send to
the remote server and the remote server
originally had like one publisher two
cues and suddenly started getting
messages from a remote
machine what this
happens uh is that we don't need to do
anything we just enable the plugin and
then we have the replication uh for
free to configure the
Federation we can set parameters that
are Json
objects like this one for example
and you can send for example to prevent
unban buffers you can tell expires if I
cannot replicate messages uh after n
milliseconds then you can delete that
queue for example or if the message is
older than n milliseconds don't send it
to the remote machine you can set uh Max
hopes you can tell rabbit how how many
servers the message can keep replicating
too you can have the ACT mode to pre to
do speed versus no message loss uh on
confirm when the remote machine tells me
uh I brought this message to the hard
drive the local or the remote server
will delete the message on publish as
soon as I put the message on the hard
drive um on the hard drive on the
network it will be deleted and Noak mode
is the leing laida Loca or the
Ala replication version let's say uh and
yeah it's the fastest one but you could
lose messages that's a URI you can use
and the do how to to set it
up you can configure it on on the
command line the or you can do it using
an HTTP API that rabbit has to
administer the whole server or on the
management interface that is like a web
browser
interface and with Federation we can
just do that we can uh do this
replication um for free let's
say not part of the talk because there
are only 50 more seconds we have some
blog post about queing Theory and how to
improve the performance of your rabbit
apps I recommend that you go there I
recommend that you read this book which
has Que in theory applied to computer
systems which is really good if you want
to improve the performance of your apps
it's a very very good
book there are stuff about how to scale
the setup that I'm not going to cover
mostly about how to do sharding with
rabbit how to Shard cues and to and the
slides with rabbit what we can do is to
get data in at least with three
different um protocols you can mix them
you can publish using mqtt and then
process using nqp for example you can
have this Internet of Things uh devices
all send in data but then using Java or
node you can process everything using
nqp on the back end with Federation we
can do this distribution then you didn't
see it but with Charing we can scale or
with with with
cues and then do some Lo balancing with
fated cues that we also didn't cover
today credits questions
no unless you have mate of course and
thank you very
[Applause]
much so I have some very good news you
won't have to listen to me a lot more
just a few more times so that's very
good news so the next speaker I want to
present is kind of awkward because I
work in outo and the next speaker also
works in outo so if I say he's awesome
you would say yeah but you work with him
so it doesn't sound so good but what I'm
going to say is that he's awesome anyway
so what he has done is he has worked in
op source with hjs and what hjs lets you
is to run in node.js code from C or
python or any other language and the
same the other way around even though
he's my coworker I actually had to just
talk to him to ask him how you pronounce
his last name because he's from Poland
and it's like really hard and to be
honest while I'm talking at this I'm
talking more because I'm trying to
remember his how you pronounce it
because I've just forgotten so I will
improvise again I love improvising so
everybody you have to give a very good
Round of Applause to Thomas the chuk who
is going to be talking about Sun boxing
in OJs with coros and Docker thank
[Applause]
you thank you so my name is Tomas yuk uh
I work for of zero with GTO uh and
during this session I'll be talking
about sandboxing no JS code um in multi
systems so uh why would you even think
about sandboxing no JS code many
multi-tenant systems enable
extensibility by allowing users to write
custom code that is then running as part
of the platform and since you since you
know very little about what that code
does and how it behaves you cannot fully
trust it so that's why you need a
Sandbox to run it
in in not zero we are offering identity
as a service and as part of the
authentication pipeline we allow people
to provide custom node.js code that we
are executing as part of every
authentication transaction people can
basically customize the the behavior the
authentication Behavior Uh for their
applications and and users that way
however given that we don't have uh full
control over what that code can do we
need a Sandbox to run that code
in uh all custom code in not zero right
runs in the context of an HTTP request
so basically the code must execute fully
within the lifetime of a single HTTP
request which is the time span of a
single authentication transaction uh
given that the sandbox model that we
required also was based on HTTP
basically you were you were sending an
HTTP post request to the sendbox the
body of the HTP post request contains
the node.js code to execute uh the
sendbox runs that code and when the
result is available it sends it back to
the caller as Json object in the HTTP
response so this is a very basic sandbox
model the program programming model
around it that we have created is also
very simple uh you are basically writing
a nodejs code that returns a JavaScript
um function closure that function
accepts a single callback parameter when
you're done executing your code you're
supposed to return the the result value
to that callback uh that result is then
serialized into Json and return to the
color what kind of properties did we
require out of that sandbox so first and
foremost we require data isolation if uh
we are executing code of one tenant we
expect that code to be unable to uh
affect execution of code from other
tenants in any way or from accessing
data of other tenants so this is the
kind of primary security uh requirement
that we had in addition to that we also
had a number of uh resource governance
um requirements around uh how memory CPU
and networking is allocated we wanted to
prevent one tenant from executing an
authenticated Doos attack against
resources of our sandbox that would
prevent other tenants from running
uh code in the same time in that
sandbox so at the very high level uh we
basically looked at what is available
out there in terms of sandboxy nodejs
code and none of the of the Shelf
components were meeting our requirements
so we' decided to build our own high
level our
sandb tenants is running every tenants
code in their own Docker
container uh in addition to that we are
creating an ER firewall around that
Docker container such that the code
running in that container can only talk
to the public internet it cannot talk to
other to endpoints exposed by other
Docker containers running on behalf of
other tenants or to uh endpoints exposed
by our sendbox infrastructure like the
proxy the controller or etcd running on
that
box so the way the system functions is
that when that HTTP post request
containing the code to execute arrives
on the box it it is first landing the
proxy component the proxy consults etcd
which is a distributed configuration
system like
zookeeper to see if a container
Associated to the particular tenant is
already running if it is that request is
then reverse proxy uh to that existing
container if the container doesn't exist
then the proxy will create a new one
associated with that tenant create a
registration in itcd for future requests
and um reverse proxy the the request to
the newly created component
in terms of uh uh preventing
authenticated us attacks against memory
CPU and other operating system resources
we are using a number of mechanisms
first and foremost we are leveraging uh
limits imposed to the cgroups level so
cgroups is a Linux me button and someone
someone's name will show up we have a
few rules uh if you if your name comes
up you can't win something else so if
you win the mate you don't win the Drone
so that's rule number one but it's a
beautiful
mate and we will give you organic yba
mate um the other rule is if you're not
here we can't give you anything so if
you hear your name or you see your name
over stream I'm sorry so even if you're
wanting to pee stay here Y and also you
can cry you can cry with joy when you
win the
Drone um all right so the first name
is I can do it
more it's taking a long time it's not
using Java Script see this is real
random that's why it's taking so much
time right yeah yeah it's super random
all right super
super it's as a cell it's so
slow so we can see that thear rou isn't
perfect titer his software has bags so
that's good for for
us we're preparing a
second um symbolized here to the
inventor of java and we could just kind
of like stick that on top of gong next
to Gecko and basically just kind of veg
it into our phone um and then we could
run messaging things on top of
that of course this is bad at least for
two reasons first of all um Java has a
really bad track record the security um
they're still finding really fundamental
bugs in Java and they often really bad
because they affect all browsers of the
same time so if you do this if you take
a Java VM and kind of like stick it into
our system since the Java VM would be
sitting directly on top of Linux and the
OS core we would basically create a
second surface for
vulnerabilities there could be like
additional bug in a Java VM and it would
create additional room for the phone to
be broken into so that's a really bad
idea to kind of put it in addition to
the rendering engine we basically have
twice as much opportunity for something
to go
wrong and then the second reason of
course is that it would be really bad
karma to put another Java VM into the
web stack right so we we got to the
point where you don't long need Java on
a desktop and with feature phones over
the next couple years going out of
fashion Java will also go out of fashion
with it so at this point putting a Java
VM into a web based and stards based and
hm my five based phone it seemed like a
really bad idea so we decided not to go
that
route so this which was about four or
five months ago we already had a large
number of phones out in the field that
all don't have the original version of
some of these messaging apps if we do it
this way since we not using any
privileged uh HMF 5 capabilities you're
not kind of trying to bypass the
platform in any way we can actually make
an app an HM 5 web app like this and
just put it in a Marketplace where
people can download it and they can use
this without having to buy a new phone
so this is very nice because we address
the existing um set of phones as
well all right the the downside of it of
course is now we have to write a Java VM
and JavaScript that's very
exciting as I said uh my background is
in writing compilers that's what I did
in Academia before uh Brandon kind of
freed me from Academia let's put it this
way and my entire background natur
evolves in Java compilers before I
started to do JavaScript compilers so
this is one of the reasons that I found
this project particularly interesting
because I have done both extensively I
have written several Java VMS and I have
written several implementations of
JavaScript compilers I never really
tried to write a Java VM on top of
JavaScript so that seemed very appealing
to
me so for the next couple slides I will
dive a little bit into technical details
and explain to you at the high level how
Java works and show you some of the
problems that I ran into trying to build
a Java VM that's really ready to run
production level code on a device like
this don't worry too much if you don't
see or understand some of the details
for example there will be no quiz after
my talk on the details of this slide
this is merely meant to kind of
highlight some of the uh Concepts you
need to understand so you can understand
the next slides so on this slide here
really the only thing you should
memorize is that Java is built from
class files every Java PR program that
you get consists of a large number of
class files and each class file
represents one class and these things
are stored in a binary format it's
basically an array of bytes that
contains information about the class
itself it contains the fields and the
methods of the class the actual code
which is stored as a bite code the bite
code you can think of as a sequence of
bytes that explains what instruction the
VM should take and the VM go step by
step through these bu code
instructions so really all you have to
do to run a Java program is you have to
find a way how you can parse these class
files and then you write an interpreter
for this language this Java bite code
language and then you run that inter
interpreter over the code that you find
in these classes and once you have one
class that's your starting class it will
call methods it can call methods in the
same class or it can call to other
classes and whenever it calls another
class you have to go and find the class
file for that other class so that's
that's the all the entire magic behind
Java now as I said the Java Java
programs consist of a large number of
these class files a popular messaging
app like WhatsApp or Viber is often
hundreds of different classes in
addition to that you also have Library
classes which are often thousands of
classes it would be of course kind of
awkward to have to carry around a
thousand files if you're installing a
Java program so what they came up with
is jar files um a jar file is uh a Java
Java likee name for a zip file so it
turns out jar files really are like zip
files they're exactly structured the
same and they're basically just a zip
archive with all the Java class files
inside of that and if you want to
distribute a Java app all you do is you
give someone a jar file and then the VM
can go and read all that stuff out of
the jar
file the first problem run into is that
as I explained what we want to do is we
want to write an app that knows how to
run a Java program and it will get that
actual Java program from whoever is
Distributing the Java program not from
us so the first step we have to make
sure of is that this Java VM that we are
writing can read these original jar
files so we need to be able to power zip
files fortunately um that's something I
had to do before so we did pdf.js a
couple years ago to display PDF
documents is HTML 5 and there as well
the first problem we have to solve is
that PDF documents are basically zip
files as well so you kind of you can see
a Meme here like everything out there is
a ZIP file basically and um we had
actually implemented for pdf.js a zip
file reader that's up on
GitHub and I had done lying around there
for like the last two years and we
didn't touch it since
then so I took zip file. JS and I wrot a
little parser for class file to kind of
see how how this goes and uh should work
great right we have we can parse class
files now we can read zip files and it
totally work didn't work at all um that
was somewhat unexpected so I spent a
good afternoon trying to find out why
the class files I was getting out of the
jar files did not make any sense and it
turns out
that if you read the specification of
zip files which I did uh it's just a
very painful process uh I I hope hope
you never have to do that it's it's
really it sucks um the specification
says that any zeros at the end of a
stream you don't have to store so if
you're storing a compressed file and the
last couple things in the file are zeros
you can leave out those zeros the
program that parses the zip file is
supposed to know that if there's
something missing just add a zero and I
somehow didn't read this right the first
time we wrote this implementation so
what the code originally did is if
you're running out of bytes in your uh
typed array and you get an undefined
back you raise an exception so this is
the error we were running into and the
fix of course is very easy we simply
read data from a bite array and then we
just or a zero in there this is a trick
we will use a little bit later on a
slide as well what this basically does
it it it forces that to be a an integer
number and undefined is the equivalent
of the integer numberb zero so whenever
we read past the end of this B stream
then we will start reading back zeros
which is exactly what the specification
calls for the neat part is that we
shipped this bug in pdf.js for years so
people have looked at like billions of
PDF documents and nobody notices that
this was wrong this must be because the
implementation of Jar files and of PDF
readers is separate so the PDF readers
seem or generators don't seem to
generate this kind of optimization with
zero at the end
so since then we actually fixed that in
Firefox as
well all right Next Step so I had now a
way to re jar files after some pain and
I had a way to parse class Files The
Next Step of course is a VM you have to
go and get something and we'll interpret
that bite code and run the actual Java
program for us the most natural way of
doing that these days would be of course
to take m scripton m scripton is this
C++ or C C++ compiler that takes
existing C++ code and it emits through
llvm and a couple other steps JavaScript
from that over last year actually we
also did an extension of that called
asm.js which I think brandan will show
in his talk in a little bit that makes
it possible to make this really
efficient so if you do this path if you
go from C C++ down to JavaScript you can
get really really close to Native
performance so if this worked this would
be great because all I have to do is
take KVM which is written in C and I
could compile that and I would have a VM
uh in my browser or in my rendering
engine in theory that's really great and
you should always reuse code if you can
however in this case I couldn't find a
license for KVM and I'm serious it's
there's no license they put out code
there they're saying that there's no
license and they don't have a license
for it so I started calling up some old
friends from Sun and uh there's really
no license out there so for some reason
it's out there there's no license right
now to use it and I couldn't find anyone
left at Oracle who knows how they we
could slap an open source license onto
it so ended up basically not be able to
use KVM because it just it's not allowed
you can only use it for research
purposes you cannot use it for any other
purpose so this was very sad um because
there's essentially no other open source
project that implements this specific
flavor of the VM there's a couple open
source VMS that Implement a more
heavyweight complete Java VMS but
nothing implements this limited
configuration that KVM needs
so one of the reasons I'm here today
with you is because Sun didn't put a
license on KVM 14 years ago uh I all
right
um so to write a VM I went on GitHub and
try to find who else tried to do this
and it turns out a whole bunch of people
have tried to write Java VMS in
JavaScript and everyone tends to do that
for about two months before they give
up so I looked at all the different
implementations that were completely in
complete and uh the one I like the best
is called node jvm I liked it because U
the code structure was may be very nice
and neat um or maybe just because his
style matched my random style very well
um but anyway this was the one that I
started with it had a classile parser
and a bunch of different other pieces
that I was able to reuse so with this
actually I was able to get the first T
World program to
work I very quickly realized that the
way that they implemented natives it's a
really bad idea so what is a native in
Java as you probably know Java is a
types safe language so there's a lot of
things you cannot do in Java you cannot
poke around with memory addresses you
cannot directly call a system call that
will invoke some service from the
operating system to do these things Java
has to somehow call into C code and this
C code is what Java calls native code
it's basically in the VM a way to
recognize that you're calling a special
magic method this is specific specific
name and that name is mapped to running
a c function instead of trying to run
actual JavaScript by code
program the way that
um the author of this VM
implemented all the Java libraries is
that he basically made every single Java
Library method a native method so he
would go ahead and JavaScript to
implement every single thing that you
need in Java in
JavaScript that again is a bad idea for
a couple different reasons first of all
there's a lot of stuff the Java library
that you need for this phones is
actually not very large it's about 1
Megabyte as a compressed jar file if you
uncompress that and because class files
are actually very compact there's
actually a ton of code there a couple
thousand classes and those classes have
a lot of different implementation
details U my life is too short to like
write all of that again in JavaScript 14
years later and again also kind of felt
bad karma to redo all this work that was
done 14 years ago so of course a much
better idea would be even though we
cannot use the same
VM that um Sun did 14 years ago we could
at least use the same libraries maybe
and this is where we got lucky um and
I'll come back in a second the second
piece that the second reason that's a
really bad idea to try to write a Java
library in JavaScript is that even
though the name is very similar and and
I'm sure Brandon has a couple more jokes
in this one
too the name is very similar but
semantically these languages are very
very different so in Java for example if
you invoke a method and give it an
object uh that is null something very
specific happens in Java and you're
supposed to raise a Java exception so
what the VM has to do basically is not
just throw an underlying JavaScript
exception but the VM has to throw a Java
exception ception has to take a
different path running bite code and it
has to give the program a chance to
react properly to that null
exception and because Java is so old and
has gone through so many rewrites and so
many so much code was written for it
Java applications tend to often really
rely on these very subtle little details
so when you're starting WhatsApp for
example it does rely on the proper
handling of a null object D reference if
you start V chat uh like this it relies
on an integer division by zero being
thrown as an exception and being
reported so it would be very difficult
to rewrite all this JavaScript code uh
all this Java code in JavaScript and
make sure that every single step you
maintain precisely the semantics of java
it would be of course much better if you
can simply take the library code AS Java
and then we simply run that in a VM then
we don't have to write the code and we
have guaranteed the right
mantics so as as I said we got lucky
here because Sun open sourced the
library parts of java just not the KVM
itself so we could simply download from
Sun's site the entire source code of the
library that you need for these phones
to work that saved a ton of effort right
there that's
great um all right let's talk a little
bit about the VM so now we have
basically all the basic pieces we have
we can read draw files we can look at
class files
we have uh the library stuff as bite
code now we need a VM that can actually
run this
code the VM itself is really
straightforward as I said earlier Java
bite code is just basically a sequence
of bytes this instructions in there
encoded there's a little bit less than
255 instructions they're numbered and
there's a definition that says if you
see uh zero in your by stream that's a
no op don't do anything just go to the
next Str if you see a one it's an it
pushes a null constant onto the Java
stack and so on so the most trivial way
of implementing this is simply you you
go ahead and uhu you write a little
interpreter it grabs the current frame
and pulls out the stack and then it does
operations on it in a infinitely
spinning wild
loop it's interesting to look at two
parts of this Loop or this instruction
execution um the one I already showed
briefly a couple slides earlier in Java
you have strict typing so in Java
actually have different by code
instructions for adding to integers or
adding to Long integers integers are
defined as 32-bit integers and Longs are
defined as 64bit integers so for integer
addition what you have to make sure is
that when you add two numbers they
always guaranteed come out as an integer
again now we could make make sure that
the number that goes in into stack pop
on those two they're always integers
however if you add two integers in
JavaScript and it's larger than a 30
Tobit integer what you get is
a right it just overflows into doubles
so JavaScript doesn't have this weird
case of java where if you go over the
definition range of an integer you can
you kind of come back out on other side
of the world where like if you add one
to the largest 32-bit integer then you
get a negative
number so that's really nice for
JavaScript but in case of um ja Java VM
we have to actually emulate the way Java
reacts here otherwise if some program
relies on this it wouldn't work anymore
use the same trick here if you or a
number of a zero you force it to be
converted to an integer number and that
way we can implement the integer
sematics of JavaScript the second one is
a long addition down there and that's
actually a little bit harder because
JavaScript cannot directly calculate
64bit numbers
you have only doubles and a part of the
doubles is reserved for essentially
telling the system where the uh period
goes so as a result of that we are using
gong. JS which is the 64-bit math
library that ships with a closure
compiler so all Longs that are generated
on the stack are basically wrapped into
those objects that allow you to do
64-bit computation fortunately on these
feature phones 64 math is very rare so
it's important to support it but it's
not really a performance
problem a more interesting instruction
is getfield um and for those of you who
don't like reading code I promise
there's only two or three slides left
before we go back to memes and and
things to laugh about um I wanted to
show a couple more examples of stuff
that was really interesting to implement
and as I said I've written several Java
VMS at this point and implementing some
of the more complex features of java
this time around in JavaScript turn out
to be very very different from any other
implementation that I've have done a
good example of is getfield what
getfield does it gets the value of a
field of a Java
object basically what it does is it
resolves the field into a slot into the
object and then tries to read from that
slot in the
object the Java specification defines
certain error conditions that can happen
one example is if you give get field a
null um object then it is
so um the reason we doing this is that
Java is a fully synchronous
language this is very different from
JavaScript where really one of the Prime
directives of JavaScript is try to run
as little code as possible in your event
Loop and don't hog the event Loop run
small Snippets of code and allow the
system to run events as well the way we
implement this this discrepancy is that
we have an outer loop that you can see
here in context prototype execute and
it's basically a loop where if the code
that we run in VM execute throws this
specific exception of VM pause or VM
yield what this code does basically it
jumps up goes back to the event handler
returns to the event Loop and then next
time they come around we will run code
again so this is essentially how we
implement the ability to take a Java
thread and at any time we can deschedule
it so the system can do something else
and of course this is also how we
Implement multitasking is a
multi-threaded system all they have to
do is basically have several of these
things posted and then you essentially
have several threads that are running at
the same
time all right I promise that you will
look at raise exception and don't worry
most of this is not interesting um the
only piece that are really interesting
is the very bottom of this if you look
at the integer array the U 8 array that
we are generating there what you're
actually seeing there is that we're hand
assembling some bite code inside that
method throwing an exception is if I
have a second method in between there so
what for example can happen is let's say
you are th trying to throw a specific
exception with a name X and that name
doesn't exist then in that case the VM
would throw an exception telling you
that a class could not be found and when
you're throwing that exception you might
run out of memory which case the VM is
going to throw out of memory exception
so you have to have this cascading we
solving that this this synthetic methods
that are throwing in between the stack
this is very neat because um the simple
structure of JavaScript allows us to do
this very efficiently because we're
using this U and8 arrays to actually
store the stack
frames I mentioned a couple minutes ago
the concept of natives natives are in
Java a way to call to the operating
system or the underlying code in
JavaScript of course there's no notion
of that we simply call in the Dom or or
into functions that implemented in a
JavaScript library soil for this VM
native methods are essentially
implementations of code in JavaScript
instead of C C or C++ of
course there a fairly simple way to
implement this what we essentially do is
when you're calling a method you supply
the name in The Bite code and we have a
little override list where we look into
do we have a native ver this name and if
so they execute that JavaScript code
instead of trying to call a Java method
in interpret
so you can see a couple implementations
here we essentially just call some
native JavaScript written code that
implements those Java
functions all right uh almost
done um one thing we did not expect is
that just how slow this would be so and
if you get un this this point we were
about 100 times slower than the
application running on the feature phone
and that was really unexpected because
most of the time if you look at Java it
really runs a lot of the complex
operations in native code the reason for
this is that back when was Java was
first
written there were no compilers yet for
Java so a lot of the lot of the Java
programs could not do a lot of heavy
computation in Java itself so the Java
language started to provide a lot of
native C implementations of very complex
functionality to compensate for the fact
that Java was so slow so we really
expected that even if you have a slow VM
for Java we should be a little bit
closer to usable than 100x
away it turns out that the main reason
for this being this slow is that there's
some very frequently called things in
any programming language let's say
comparing to Strings this is called in
Java
equals in Java all these things are
implemented in Java itself so if you're
comparing two Str strings you have to
call this function here and don't worry
I will not try to read through this what
this does all you have to remember is
that there's like 80 bytes or so of
instructions in here and I highlighted
this red a loop that's inside of this so
what this code does it hases a whole
bunch of checking with its video string
and then it goes to that Loop and it for
every single character it individually
Compares whether it matches the other
string or not and then returns true or
false and of course each of these steps
in this program are Java VM written
JavaScript has to interpret so comparing
two strings in this Java VM we just
wrote is horribly slow we did a little
profile uh using using the def tools and
we could immediately see that most of
the time was spent in 56 functions like
this so a very easy way to fix that of
course is to use the same mechanism we
just solve as native methods a native
method again is something that we
Implement in JavaScript instead of in
Java so we can simply take shortcuts so
I have a little native method that
overrides the pure Java implementation
and it goes ahead and simply checks that
it's a string and if so it does a string
compare at a JavaScript level that's of
course massively faster because the the
JavaScript VM in the browser knows how
to do that very efficiently you don't
have to like Circle that interpreter
Loop all the
time so after the disw work of course we
expected things to get a lot better and
um they did get a lot better it it got
like 10 times faster or so um but it was
still kind of painfully slow to use and
the reason for that probably is that
actually Java has advanced quite a bit
since its early days and today most the
time when you run Java programs you
actually also compile them over to um
x86 or arm machine code so even on these
simple feature phones there's actually a
compiler built in that takes the bite
code and then instead of just running an
interpreter it generates machine code
from the bite code and then runs that
machine code and since we still had an
interpreter we were slower than the
these feature phone systems to the point
where the app was not really
usable so the the next step of course is
how to compile Java in JavaScript and
this seemed like a really daunting task
for anyone who has written compilers so
for those of you who had the the the
curse or privilege whichever way you
want to see it to ever have written a
compiler generating code in a compiler
is like the most painful part of
compilers because machine code is so
hard to read and very hard to Target and
it's also the most exciting thing to
debug like there's there you have not
debugged in your life until you have
trying to debug some machine code that
goes wrong on you and you're trying to
understand what the hell happens there
in some like binary machine code you're
looking at so when it got to this point
this seemed pretty scary quite honestly
because every time I had done it before
um it it was a really daunting task to
deal
with fortunately um this is Javascript
right and it it is it is not machine
language it's not x86 and it's not arm
and it's a lot easier to do this in
JavaScript and this was almost
unexpected for us if you look at the
compiler that is in jm. JS that is
probably the smallest Java compiler I've
ever
seen if you think about it for a moment
what it does it takes a Java code and of
course emits JavaScript code from it it
all a sudden of course makes a lot of
sense that it's a very small compiler
because what you're doing is almost like
an inversion JavaScript is actually a
much more semantically Rich language
than Java and it has much more powerful
Primitives what we're doing is we're
basically taking Java and we are
lowering it to this much higher
representation this this is of course
very easy because many things where you
have to painfully assemble in um machine
code instructions for Java are very very
trivial to do in
JavaScript we also harnessed a couple
other tricks to make this process
particularly easy when you're trying to
compile Java over to JavaScript we try
to use edges much of the JavaScript
semantics itself so for example Java
objects are represented through one
JavaScript object we not trying to
implement our own garbage collector we
are not trying to implement many other
pieces of the Java VM that traditionally
you have to implement in some native
language so by making our Java
implementation match very very closely
what the JavaScript language does the
actual compilation approach itself
becomes really
trivial so this what compilation looks
like and this this will look eie
familiar to you if you remember the the
execute Loop it essentially does the
same thing that the execute function did
there a compile function you go over the
bu code in sequence and for every bu
code operation you simply emit some code
and code in this case is simply a string
if we Define up there and we concatenate
into that string operations in
JavaScript that basically emulate the
stack nature of java and execute the
operations that Java is executing so
this turned out to be really a very easy
way to compile
code this part was really easy but was a
lot less easy is actually trying to run
that
code we are running this stuff in an
environment where content security
policies are enforced and if you don't
know what it is I recommend you go and
read right after this talk because it's
very important that you know what it is
um for those of you who don't know yet
CSP is a way how you can
restrict um web applications from doing
dangerous things and AAL is one of those
things is pretty dangerous because if
you have stuff coming in from the user
and it somehow gets into a that's
usually where things go wrong and some
someone is going to take over your code
and inject some code so we are in an
environment where we can actually not
use a Val so we can compile a Java
program just find the JavaScript but
then we cannot actually eval it because
the eval function itself self is uh
disallowed I unfortunately don't have
time to go all the evil details that it
takes to bypass that but essentially
what we doing is we are firing up a new
iframe and we load the code in that new
iframe and that if frame kind of post
messages us back and forth um as we
execute code and it it it actually even
works so um this was even surprising to
me one of the other authors Mick on this
project came up with this idea and it's
pretty insane if you really would like
to see some fun code I recommend you
take a look at
that all right now we at the demo part
of this um it seems that the convention
is when MOA comes to demo or at least
when a MOA CTO comes to demo something
at a JSC conference you have to show
some sort of live demo and Brandon
already said the precedent that it
usually it is a game that you're playing
uh there is no Quake for j2me as far as
I know uh so I I picked the second
closest thing I could find and this is a
live demo so if it doesn't work I'm very
sorry
um let's see where my
bookmarks there we go so this is the
asteroids
um Java game that is common on these on
these phones and uh great the resolution
is screwing me here I cannot get to my
start
button see it's that's
great it's live debugging here all right
now it works um all right so I can go to
menu here so this is all the Java stop
that's running this is the interpret
Loop running here running this asteroid
game this a jar file this actually an
open source um j2me game you can find on
the web it's on GPL it's really great if
you have to debug a VM if you have a
program you have the source code for
trying try to debug with something that
you only have to buy code for that's
really
painful so here this is this are touch
events from the browser that are sent
over to um to the Java VM and I can go
ahead here and start this this
everything you see here like this this
very ugly yellow UI this is all rendered
in Java in like 14y old Java code that
runs on these phones and I can start
this and then uh
I'm live demo I cannot move my ship so
this is unfortunate um let's see if you
if you can do this if you start this
again no I still cannot all right I
cannot tell you if I cannot move my ship
right now it worked in a room there you
can believe me or not um but in theory I
would give you live live demo right now
next time I'm definitely going to record
this and not show this live all right
let's go back to our
slides all right before I run out of
time um first of all thank you very much
for listening to me uh going on about
Java and JavaScript and VMS written in
JavaScript I would like to acknowledge a
couple people um that have worked on
this project as with many of the other
projects that I started in the past it's
usually me who gets to do the first fun
couple weeks and a bunch of people have
to come in who have to like do months of
hard work to actually make it work so um
there's a whole bunch of people from
Mozilla and also outside contributors to
help the j2me get it to the point where
it can run uh Java applications and uh I
recommend you look up their names if
you're interested in the code for this
it's all up on GitHub and uh check it
out and run some j2me stuff in your
browser thank you very
much
all right last Talk of the
day before I get started uh remember
that you can tweet with hjs ar uh if you
have any questions I'm sure that blew
your mind and you're going to have a lot
of questions uh so obviously Mr Brendan
Ike has has no introduction needed but I
want to clarify and I want to thank him
because what he did to get to Argentina
today is really extraordinary I want to
thank
Meola uh because uh they took care of
everything to make sure he's here today
he's flying in and out of the country in
the same day just to be with us today so
please let's welcome him with a huge
round of
applause
is not
him let's
see did it work
oh let's
hope wow that looks
terrible is that the right
resolution is it
good it's such a big
screen can we do
better should I try dare I
try no I'm okay all right I'm GNA not
going to mess with this because I've had
this thing crash on
me I'm going to talk about the future of
JavaScript I'm always talking about the
future um so as Santana said if you if
you don't study history you're condemned
to repeat it I think that's true if you
do study history too um so the future of
JavaScript is
Java because that's also the past I'm
only only slightly
kidding I have to go back to 1995 which
was um when I was small
and JavaScript was created in a mad
tearing
hurry and I was thinking about this not
only because of andreas' talk about J2
me. JS but also because um I don't know
I missed the '90s
box.com had this picture in their piece
about how that was the last great
television season
9495 there's like my so-called life and
party of five and and um
friends that's when I got my big break
this is me before my hair went
gray JavaScript had something to do with
that I'd go to um back then you couldn't
find things on the web like you can now
now I think you can find a lot of a lot
of computer science papers not all of
them some of them are still locked up um
behind you know pay walls but back then
you had to go to a real library and
actually read bound journals and that's
what I did I would go to this place this
is uh Margaret Jack Hall at least the
front corner of it in um Stanford
University in California and I would go
read papers in among the
stacks I also maybe I there because I
read that John dor said he's a famous
venture capitalist that any idiot could
make a lot of money just by hanging
around Margaret Jack's Hall that's the
computer science offices that's where
the computer science professors um have
their offices and office hours that's
where the computer science library is
that's the library that I was going to
um I didn't I didn't become a successful
venture capitalist unfortunately but I
did read a paper or two including one
about Java Vite code and this was right
before I did the 10 days of work to
create the first JavaScript engine I was
still thinking about Java even though
the Java VM that the friend of mine Kip
Hickman at Netscape had started building
had been killed Netscape was doing a
deal with sun and Bill Joy at Sun said
we can't have two Java VMS because they
they wouldn't have bug for buug
compatibility Netscape has to use Sun's
source code to actually make their be
only one implementation of java
otherwise it'll fail now he was right
bill I think Bill Joy was right if if we
tried to reverse engineer or even got
source code access and built our own jbm
we would have had lots of bugs getting
them to interoperate and indeed when
JavaScript came out and Microsoft
reverse engineered it there were a lot
of bugs in both engines and we had to
write a
St overloaded for multiple types and you
have to do crazy analysis to verify the
code and do an assignment analysis and
do other things to make sure it's safe
JavaScript was all untyped so I couldn't
use the Insight in this paper about
modeling the types as you read the the
code modeling the stack machine that
Java uses in an abstract way doing
abstract interpretation but I did use
that idea for the decompiler that I put
in you know when you make a function
turn into a string in in JavaScript
engines ever since I wrote the first one
that I'm familiar with um some of them
actually go find the source or save the
source and give you that Source back as
the two- string result the ones I've
built up until um somebody at Mula
ripped it out the other year used a
decompiler so they would actually take
an internal form like a bite code and
turn it back into a string and I used
the idea from this paper to build that
and I also thought at the time why do we
need typed bite code Java already has
types in it's you know class files has
descriptions of all the types of the
static and instance Fields it has Type
signatures for all the methods why do we
need to have Types on the bik codes
too here's another um thing from the
paper it shows um class Vector this is
just like old Java and then it shows the
metadata CLI data so you could always
figure the types out from the the fields
and the static members and all the
signatures on the methods you didn't
need to have the the the intermediate
instructions carry types and
proliferate but there were other
problems that CLR by code did not fix or
the intermediate code for net did not
fix um meanwhile JavaScript was there
kind of slow in the 90s but still going
somewhere and finally taking off in the
last 11 years I'd
say
so now it's
2014 lot of water under the bridge
Java's pretty much dead on the client
plugins like Andreas set or a malware
Vector especially turns out the Java
plugin um I think Brian kreb's security
analyst said that it was the number one
in its day it's probably not anymore
number one vector for malware that
people would pay for for for uh black
hat malware that's bought and
sold asm.js is a thing it's a set of
JavaScript it's like carving nature at
the joints like Plato said it's it's
finding inside JavaScript thanks to the
bitwise and shift operators that I put
in that were in Java and c and I put
them in because they were in C it's
finding the subset that is typed in a
way that can be very efficiently
compiled to the machine to the metal um
and es6 is all but done there's there's
you know uh Jon's talk this morning had
a nice chart summarizing it but here's
the um here's the more hardto read chart
and if you look at who's winning it's
usually um oh it's iie now the technical
preview for iie now has the most of es6
implemented good for Microsoft followed
by Echo JS by somebody I knew at
Netscape Chris toshok followed by Tracer
Eric Aron's compiler that compiles es60
to JavaScript es5 and then Firefox 35 is
is is second after the browser uh in the
front which is IE ouch um
so es6 is kind of The Last of The Bigs
it it it was so big and so connected we
didn't want to cut it up into pieces but
after es6 we're going to do smaller
annual releases I'll talk about this in
a few minutes um es6 did absorb typed
arrays so there's that word typed again
now these aren't like Java typed like
you have to write down the types but
these are you know int 32 array and you
know float 32 array these are very
important for working with the GPU and
with simd units which are also coming
up and then um typed objects in es7 kind
of take away the wackiness the fixed
length nature in particular of typed
arrays and allow you to have
descriptions runtime descriptions of all
your types of your properties if you
want to so typed objects will allow you
to imperatively through an API not
declaratively say what the types of
properties in an object are and they can
be packed together they can be flat they
can be extremely efficient it's kind of
a generalization of typed
arrays and so then we also have
typescript and something that it
inspired according to uh the Facebook
guys flow uh and flow looks very very
good because they they've done a
sophisticated analysis or set of
analyses really that allow them to
capture a lot of the idiomatic
JavaScript without just giving up and
saying saying I can't I can't type this
I'm going to just make it to type any
um everyone's really keen on seeing
where these things go but back to the
the class example from java I've
Rewritten an es6 using typed arrays
using a little bit of asm.js type
casting like Andreas said if you see
that vertical bar zero that's bitwise or
zero that is a cast to
in32 and you probably know the other
idioms for doing this there's
triple right shift zero is cast to un32
and um twiddle twiddle
X is a conversion to int um and you can
do other things pretty efficiently you
can use plus as as a unary operator to
make arbitrary value become a double so
asm.js relies on these type casts this
isn't exactly pretty but this will
generate in a modern engine that can
handle the syntax like maybe the IE
preview one this will generate as good
code as any Java VM would on that old
goling code so I I
say jvms
are basically taking the dynamic untyped
route to the same promised land that
Java was was promising which didn't get
delivered in the browser by Java it got
delivered by JavaScript we're almost
there with typed objects type areas I
think will be
there as Darth said the circle is now
complete I guess this makes JavaScript
Darth Vader and um James goling is
Obi-Wan
uh anyway
um let me talk about standardization
because there there's always angst about
how long it takes to do a standard and
es6 is big I was involved in ES4 which
helped get the standards body back in
shape through the harmony peace process
that I uh brokered
but thank you standardization uh is
going to go faster now that's Ian
hixon's signature line I don't know if
it's original to him things that are
impossible just take
longer we're not going to take years and
years anymore we're doing um we're doing
better here's how it looked though in
2011 when I spoke at TX JS I I took a
picture of the tc39 meeting right before
then um and it looked like that
and then um there's also some some
famous artist in Italy did a picture of
crock and me
um Croc's Plato and I'm Aristotle um and
I'm like cool it you know quit pointing
up I I actually miss Croc he he doesn't
come to tc39 anymore and I looked around
at the last meeting and I didn't see him
and I actually felt sad even though he
he he gets pretty grumpy but we need we
need the grumpy idealists we need the
Playdoh where would Aristotle be without
Playdoh
so now even without Croc it's kind of a
loss um we
have tc39 doing its work on GitHub my
image is too big um you can actually see
almost everything that's happening there
I think all the the um the tests are
moving there I believe the specification
is going to move there it still has to
be done in word if you can believe it
because of the Way Emma and ISO work but
modu of the word issue it's it's also an
HTML as a first class source for the
specification and people can send poll
requests the meeting notes are kept um
on GitHub and also available on es.org
they're captured originally on I think
it's Alex seon's okay so clap um
etherpad or somebody's anyway Ean tc39
is no longer working in Smoke filed
rooms or or arguing in robes in in the
Greek um Marketplace um of ideas we're
actually working on GitHub which is good
news and for es7 and Beyond we're going
to work on an annual Cadence where it's
like the Chrome and Firefox release
process if proposals don't make it
through a multi-stage waterfall they
just don't ship that year they have to
take a later train so the trains always
ship on time so es7 should be
implemented some pieces of it are
actually implemented now should be
implemented next year and finalized
there's always a little bit of dotting
the eye delay finalized in
2016 and as you know es6 is going to be
finalized middle of next year so
standards are getting better now Jason
did such a good job about covering es6
that I thought I'd just talk about a few
es7 things that you might not have heard
about how many people here use promises
in in some Library other good okay
so you may know that generators which I
think Jon didn't cover are in es6 and
I'll show them in a minute but this
example from luk cin from Microsoft on
the um he was on the ecma committee
until last year shows if you were using
promises to chain animations say you had
an array of animations and you use this
nice es6 forl anim of animations Loop to
iterate over the values of the
animations array it's like four in but
it's over the values then for each
animation you'd have to chain using a
promise and using p then to call that
animation and it's kind of a verbose and
then at the end you'd have to worry
about whether there was an exception
which you'd probably ignore and youd
finally with a final then at the bottom
return the the return value of of The
Last Promise fulfillment value of The
Last Promise which is what's being
captured by this Rett variable notice
I've used let everywhere there's no vs
um so that's that's okay but you can do
better with with generators so in es6
function star makes a generator sort of
like python inspired by python with some
simplifications and the task JS library
from Dave Herman has a function called
spawn you pass a
generator function function star to a
spawn call and you get uh a scheduler in
the background that will resume that
generator for you and that generator can
then yield each animation in turn notice
that there are no promises here anymore
the promises are hidden inside the spawn
Machinery in the scheduler that tjs
implements so already this has gotten a
lot simpler because it doesn't have
promises with their Lambda callbacks um
and it can use TR catch directly whereas
the previous slide had to use the
promise. catch method and couldn't use
Tri catch notice also the arrow
functions here which make it nice and
short it wouldn't fit on my slide
otherwise but even with arrows it's it's
a little much whereas with with tjs and
spawn and generators it gets shorter and
you can use real exception handling with
tri
catch what we want to do for es7 is go
one step further and this is again I
think due to Luke hobin originally at
Microsoft and I think this is a good
consensus in the committee and that's
allow async to be used as
a
non-reserved conditional keyword a
contextual keyword in front of function
so that you can make this chain
animation async function be an async
function and once you say it's an ASN
function up there at the top then inside
it you can say await and you see the
await takes the place of the yield in
the previous
version and there's no function star and
there's no spawn call you don't need to
use task JS the scheduler gets absorbed
into the es7 version of the language so
async functions will not only de
promisify a lot of your code they will
remove generators and task JS
boilerplate and allow you to write
something like this which I think is
pretty
important because we're javascript's
going to be async in the browser forever
and it should be even if we have lots of
new um ways of composing workers and we
might end up making ways to make the non
foreground UI thread workers block async
is the way to go so and that's true in
node to so I wanted to share
that and then quickly run through other
things that are on board you may know
about simd I'll give a little demo is
single instruction multiple data it's
architecture acronym that describes
Vector units
short units that uh short um vectors
that contain integers or floating Point
numbers packed usually four 32bit Floats
or 4 32bit ins but they come in
different sizes 8 16bit 168 bit
generally they're multiplying to 128
bits Intel's more recent work also has
256 bit long vectors and they all get
pieced up into power of two sizes for
integers and floating points pretty
important for speeding up DSP code game
code physics code Graphics
code typed objects I
mentioned value objects which include
notably finally N64 and
u64 for
real and that means we don't want to
just hardcode these so we're going to
make userdefined operators and literals
in the language so you can have your own
operators probably makes sense for
people using matrices and vectors even
mutable objects could have operators and
you can go to town and a async
generators I showed you async functions
async generators would
be sort of what they sound like um
that's something that's being uh worked
on by uh Jafar s of Netflix
so es7 is going to be smaller you can
tell this isn't nearly as big as that
giant kangax chart and maybe some stuff
will get cut but we'll get it done it'll
be back next year implemented next year
and finalized uh into the beginning of
the following year here and that's
exciting um but nothing beats uh
excitement um like a demo so I'm going
to try to show some things
here first of all this is the demo from
um the Intel folks showing how simd can
speed up your code here's a mandal br
generator and if you don't have simd it
starts off a little under 30 frames a
second and it degrades because the
complexity is growing
as we zoom in if I say use
simd it zooms up by almost factor of
four and it will it will again fluctuate
depending on the complexity but it's
still roughly between three and four
times faster because it's getting that
four fold speed up for the
parallelizable parts of the code by
using four float 32s or four in 32s at a
time it's using vectors so all the
additions or all the multiplications
happen at
once so
game developers and people writing um
all sorts of things will will benefit
from this now I don't want to make it
sound like it's all about games but it
kind of it's important to give games
their due because they stress test
everything I think I saw the CTO valve
many years ago at game developer
conference say that only games were
really pushing as applications as a
class of applications only games were
really pushing on you know
concurrency parallel
Hardware Vector units simd GPU
programming um aggressive memory
management so games were like the the
really hard case and this demo um I'll
start with
is the banana bread game based on the
open source Cube 2 engine a C++ codebase
that's compiled to JavaScript bym
scripton it's compiled the asm.js this
version is fun because it embeds um Doom
the free version and and so you can be
in the outer game I'm going to have to
kill this bot before it kills me um
there's a bot that's going to come out
in a minute and you can see this in game
is on the wall
there and if you
um okay remove
bot if you hit vertical bar now I'm
playing the inner game to prove this
isn't a video on YouTube as somebody
accused me of running I'll let you guys
tell me which game first episode second
episode third
episode you should
clap third all right this one I'm going
to use please don't kill
me I believe um control shoots yes the
arrow keys turn so the outer game is
like WD to move around and the inner
game is arrow
keys I think I can strafe yeah I can
strafe with great greater than and less
than and slash does something I'm not
sure what and there are monsters in the
inner game this is like oh yeah do I
have to
like how do I hit
that
there now I'm in trouble so I'm playing
the inner game it ah Tacko
demon all
right come on I
I
Okay now what's what's really cool about
this is um there's
a where is
it oh it's in my offc screen banana
bread thank you let's get out of
this there there's just a few hundred
lines of JavaScript to glue the inner
game to the outer game using a worker
this is from alone zakai you can see
um he sets up a worker that contains
boone. JS Boon is the name of the free
Doom code and that's in a separate JS
file and it runs as the worker source
and
then and then this is Unreal Engine 3
which is still a good demo um when I
mentioned Java bite
code here is the new Java bite code this
is this is the actual um
it's going to take a while it's it's big
it's asm.js so it looks quite
voluminous but more fun to see the game
let's go
here so this is I hope it's going to
make
sound I hear it does anybody else I
think it's only
me somebody has to stick a mic here
um oh good
and
then I'll show you my Mad
Skills these
are it's it's uh fully playable smooth
60 frames a second and I'm cheating
massively I'm in god
mode that's
good get really nice effects if you look
at the god Rays from the Sun see the ray
tracing this is all webg and asm.js code
which is not so pretty but there's your
modern bike code right there's um
there's your ja Java has a very number
of if greater than or if equal uh
branching conditional branching
instructions JavaScript has the if
statement Java has you know integer
operations there's your or zero that's
that's your um cast to integer so I just
wanted to show that okay last thing is
um not only the Epic Unreal Engine but
also the unity engine has been cross
compiled with them scripton and its
runtimes ported to the web so Unity is
supporting HTML 5 webgl as a first class
Target asm.js as a first class Target
um this is Dead Trigger
2 it's pretty fun the best part of this
game is the the Sentry
chickens they have machine guns on their
back so they they take care of those
zombies for you no no problem and
um again smooth
gameplay oh he's trying to crawl after
me ah they got them these kamakazi guys
will try to blow you
up so
best thing to do with them is a
grenade I'm not in god mode here but I'm
I'm doing okay I can take some health
just in case oh there's that big
kamakazi guy watch out uh-oh
grenade second
grenade ah
good okay all
right
so like I said games are fun and all and
kind of violent um but they also the you
know
the that if you can dodge a wrench you
can dodge a ball test so if you can run
these games you can you can um run a lot
of code um and that's why I always close
these talks with this homage to uh
Wesley Snipes in passenger 57 another 9
movie was not not that great um Wesley's
always awesome when he gets his martial
arts face on but um always been on JS it
was it was never going to win it was
this incredible um Underdog for too many
years and then when it started coming up
there was still flash there was Java
plugin pretty much all JavaScript now
all the browser vendors are acting
serious about it we're evolving it we're
going onto a Rapid Release process we're
adding all the hardware apis you need to
do everything with the
machine and it's kicking us ass so
always bet on JS thank you very
[Applause]
much
all right
Hey so uh now we're going to do the Q&A
with Andreas and Brandon uh we have five
questions selected from your tweets uh
so please take a seat
here this is so exciting I'm so close to
him I have a fablet loaded with
questions so the first one came from a
tweet that's I think it's really really
interesting so Brandon at what point did
you start imagining that JavaScript
could one day run and control robots or
games within games or zombies in webgl
compiled from C++ I think I think around
the time friends went off the
air and I lost my my gig there as
Chandler uh no I I I didn't foresee all
that I I thought um it was going to be a
glue language or what some people call a
duct tape language which is really I
think not not a meaningful phrase it was
going to be the little you know brother
or the sidekick to Java and Java would
do all the applets and components and
beans and those would be in your browser
and JavaScript would just be how you
glued them together sort of like Visual
Basic was to C++ in Microsoft's Windows
environment of the time but um Java
never really got out of the applet cage
it never loaded quickly it never learned
about the Dom so I think that that was
fatal awesome so basically Javas was
only going to be for embedding applets
now it's for Reinventing the jvm inside
JavaScript it's pretty
awesome um so another thing that comes
up a lot is Javascript to some people
has good parts and bad parts and now
with olds um script 6 and seven
Innovations and additions it creates new
opportunities for now narrowing down
again do you foresee that people are
going to be creating JavaScript the good
parts again now that we get all these
new features I think this is true of the
web in general like
HTML has bad parts CSS I think we all
know has bad parts um the funny thing is
people think when you have an evolving
system that if a new requirement comes
into the system you have to evolve
quickly that's not how it works in
nature you already have to have had the
genetic diversity and and already have
evolved to survive the new disease or
the new Predator so the same with
JavaScript and and HTML and CSS they're
going to have too much in them they're
going to have mistakes they're going to
have things that you can't remove
because they already are used by some
pages or apps on the web but they can be
deprecated and they can fade away and so
I you know I I just tweeted back earlier
before coming on stage I don't agree
with crockford he's too prescriptivist
for my taste he says you know there the
bad parts you must never use and there
are these little good parts that I say
you should use like the closure pattern
against the prototypal pattern it's too
it's too extreme um and JavaScript
needed to have more patterns or more
strength to it in order to survive for
unforeseen circumstances it needs to
keep evolving as it has so I I think
there will continue to be messy
Evolution with bad parts and we won't
even know they're bad until later that's
the that's the
killer if you want to add
yeah
hello is it off here has no opinion can
we hello no it works all right yeah I
think especially the part around
removing things being difficult is very
true um brenan's explanation reminded me
of a property I found in in a Dom in
mz's implementation a couple years ago
it's called Navigator do enable taint
and Brandon added that like 15 years ago
and it always returns fals because you
never actually implemented taint
propagation and uh I asked him kind of
yelling across the desk like what the
hell is this thing and and what does it
do and why is it here and in my moment
of like attempted Purity I submitted a
patch to remove that property because
clearly like it's this is nobody would
use this it was added 14 years ago for a
Fe Fe that never got implemented right
and this this went for to ride the train
in Firefox and uh I I broke like half
the web because it turns out that jQuery
uses that to detect whether you're
running on Firefox or not so
um that's really great only at GS com do
get Applause for breaking like half the
web that's awesome thank you very much I
feel much better about it already so
yeah this removing this kind of stuff is
is very hard it has to be very slow we
have removed stuff in the past
successfully like and E Forex for
example was removed after some pain so
it is possible it simply takes a lot of
time there's a I think there's a
biologist who wants to um breed chickens
to express what are called genetic
atavisms chickens with teeth like
dinosaurs because that that old enabled
taint method is still down there in
their DNA somewhere
maybe they can get teeth maybe um maybe
en Nable taint will come back I don't
know actually I have a a very hard
question for Andreas I think because he
talked so much today about JavaScript
being a great Target for compilation so
when should we use rust and when should
we use
JavaScript so rust was designed for a
very specific purpose to rewrite system
parts and um there's actually no
necessary hard distinction between these
two languages I already talked to the
team with rust should be able to Target
JavaScript there might be some cases
where it makes sense to use rust to
implement something that runs on top of
the web stack in JavaScript and there
might be other cases where it makes
sense to implement system parts with
JavaScript so I I don't think there's a
necessary order there and I would be
surprised if we don't have a rust to
JavaScript compiler at some point yeah I
agree uh the rust's main sweet spot is
safety with the same memory control that
C++ gives you right and you mentioned
types today and uh in the community we
see a lot of different projects for
tackling types in JavaScript so we have
at script now coming out typescript flow
Dart just kidding so what do we do which
one do we use what do you think about
this projects do you think uh once again
that the better one will win and the
rest will die out I think we're we're
still in the early days there's been
some interest in uh egma tc39 the
standards body about standardizing
something to do with types maybe based
on typescript and flow both using the
colon annotation like the ml languages
do like um Pascal you remember that does
um alol languages um some of them anyway
that syntax uh varx colon T you can't
just standardize it it has meaning if
you define it it it has something to say
about the types system and the type
expressions or type annotations so we're
not going to rush to standardizing that
the only thing we're doing now is saying
that no engine can go claim as an
extension on its own that colon after
the name and the Declaration that that's
reserved to the Future standards that
might standardize it I think typescript
and then flow inspired by it much more
powerful should keep going I think the
best thing they can do is get adoption
the worst thing that you could do is
make designed by committee you know
Union of all the the systems or
intersection of all the systems or some
committee Frankenstein standard that
would be terrible
all right and the final question uh for
you Brandon uh someone was wondering
about what what are the biggest lessons
or takeaways from tc39 and in general
the approach that has been taken towards
improving JavaScript and where do you
see that going in the future it's been a
long road I think that my big takeaways
in like 20 year terms are you need
competition to drive the vendors to
cooperate in the standards bodies then
you need good social relations among the
members of the committee even you know
Croc is welcome back anytime in my book
um you you need to get on this Rapid
Release footing we're trying to get on
with es7 you don't want to do big
indefinite projects in software or in
standardization because they always
suffer scope creep and the world moves
out from under them and they become
irrelevant dinosaurs so some kind of
Rapid Release footing with implementers
constantly implementing w3c
really originally the whatwg tried to
get browsers to do this with HML 5 and
that became a big living document
standard but I think now things are
getting across the web space onto a
faster cycle and that's that's one of
the biggest lessons for me all right all
right thank you so much
guys
thanks I like this
taet
so uh now I'm going to get out of the
way for a parting gift for all of us uh
that we um it's basically going to be a
surprise followed by a party so stay
tuned
[Music]
I had a dream so big and loud I jumped
so high I touch the clouds wo oh oh oh
oh oh W oh oh oh oh oh I stretch my
hands out to the sky we dance with
monsters through the night wo oh oh oh
oh oh wo oh oh oh oh oh I'm never going
to look back wo I'm never going to give
it up no please don't wake me now 2 3
4 this is going to be the best day of my
life
my this is going to be the best day of
my
life
I how at the Moon with friends and then
the sun came crashing in wo oh oh oh
oh but all the possibilities No Limits
just epiphanies
wo oh oh I'm never going to look back wo
I'm never going to give it up no just
don't wake me
now it's going to be this feeling me
this is got to be the best day of my
life everything is looking up everybody
up
now this is going to be the best day of
my
[Music]
life
come on
team see Al speaker any of you talk to
paa you know how amazing she
is
[Applause]
w
when
fore
[Music]
w
it's walking distance from here so let's
all go to the party
[Music]
now Liv pretending no answer to our
questions we just to far going remember
we had everything we were so and now
we're nothing like we used to be yeah
yeah